Oh no, okay, there we go, there we go.
Okay, sorry, I forgot that I have to redo all my output and input because my PC had to update because I realized that there's so many...
Okay, so long story short, my PC hasn't been updated, like Windows updated for like a couple of months now, for like five, six plus months, so apparently there's something wrong with my Windows.
It's fucking Windows 11, there's always something wrong.
It's Windows 11, there's always something wrong.
So like, okay, so I had this issue where every time I try to Windows update, it wouldn't let me, it would be like restarting and then like applying updates.
And then every time I try, it would update, it would say, it'd be like, something is wrong.
Something is wrong.
So like, we couldn't apply your update, but don't worry, we can revert the changes.
And then like, and then whatever.
So it would do that for six plus months.
And I didn't know why, because I kept looking it up.
And everybody's like, this is a Windows 11 problem.
And I was like, okay, you think I wanted Windows 11?
It was already installed in the, it was already there.
I got a free PC and it's already there.
I'm not going to be complaining.
The PC was free.
I'm not going to complain.
Anyway, um, anyway, but I'm complaining about this because, okay, so I'm complaining about it because like, I'm still going to complain about it, but I don't blame, I'm just going to blame Windows 11.
Anyway, so I finally got a thing where it was like, we're going to re, we're going to reinstall Windows 11 with a repaired version, um, and it will fix everything.
I don't know if it fixed everything, but like, I was just like, all right, cool.
I mean, like, I hope that it worked.
Today was the day.
I was like, all right, I hope that worked.
You know, I could actually, oh no, it didn't.
Updates failed.
Oh, okay.
It still gave me an install error.
Like, okay, nevermind.
It didn't work.
It just said update failed.
That's cool.
Your device is missing important security updates.
Make sure you keep your device on and plugged in so the updates can complete.
Oh, cool.
Um, I don't, it didn't work.
It didn't work.
I had to reset my entire, I had to repair, install a repaired version, but it didn't repair.
I'm eating my lunch right now.
I have a problem.
I like how at first I was like, I don't have a problem.
I don't have a problem.
I have a small addiction.
Now I know I have a problem.
I woke up.
I brushed my teeth.
Okay.
I did.
Sorry.
I did brush my, I always brush my teeth.
I brushed my teeth.
I woke up.
Um, I walked dad.
I fed dad.
I walked dad.
Oh my god, wait, did I actually brush my teeth?
No, I did.
I know I did because like, um, I had, I did because like, uh, yeah, sometimes I would brush my teeth when I shower.
And I did that yesterday, but I will put the toothbrush next in the back.
Like I'll put the toothbrush and the toothpaste like, um, in the shower area.
So then today I had to grab it, grab it from the shower area and then brush my teeth.
So, so like, so then I know, I know I did because it's not at the bath area.
It's not in the shower area.
It's at the, it's at the sink area.
So I did.
Sorry.
Okay.
Anyway, I have a problem.
We all know I have a problem, but like, basically I woke up, brushed teeth, fed dad, walked him, came back.
Rivals.
But I ended it 30 minutes ago because I was like, I have stream.
I have stream.
I have to do the stream.
I posted that I got GM one.
I lost GM one yesterday.
I am for 30.
I'm 30 points away from losing GM two.
So it was a very fast journey.
I got to be GM one for two games.
Uh, so today I'm gonna try and get it back.
So it was, it sucked because, um, when you do rank, you do rank fully.
You do rank like, you do rank like 20 plus points.
Like, no, not even 20, plus seven, eight, nine, seven, eight, nine.
It minuses 30 plus points.
And then my first game, I got the first game, my teammates were really fucking stupid.
My second game, we played against hackers.
And then it sort of went downhill after that.
It really, it really did.
It really went downhill.
And after that, it was win, loss, win, loss, win, loss.
So then I'm like, all right, we'll do this again after the stream.
Mori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so proud of you.
Brushed your teeth.
Did you remember to wash your hands?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Mori.
Thank you, thank you.
How many games did the GM win?
It is, I'm at 31 points right now.
So four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Uh, four, four to five games.
Four to five games, I might be able to get it back.
If I, if I can win four to five games in a row.
Anyway, um, anyway.
I want to tell this story.
So, diet update.
Doki Ember Doge update.
I didn't tell the story.
I told the story already, but I think when, what, I don't remember what stream it was where I told this story randomly.
Was it, I, what stream was it that I told?
I was like, oh, I'll tell the story again.
Was it the Marvel Rivals stream?
Um, oh yeah, I think it was, but I'll sit, this is, I'll tell, tell the story on YouTube.
So, basically, a couple days ago, um, I was walking dad.
And then, and then he was like, so like, the thing is, he doesn't have a lot of friends.
He doesn't really have, he doesn't have friends at all.
He's just like me.
Like, IRL.
Like, he's very, he's an anti-social.
Oh my god, he's just like me for real, for real.
Um, but like, he's like an incredibly like, he's, he's sort of like anti-social in a way.
So like, he hates dogs that are bigger than him, but like, he's okay with dogs that are smaller than, he's like okay with dogs that are smaller than him.
So, um, the thing about that is that whenever, so when he sees a dog that's smaller than him, he's like, oh yes, now I'm the big dog here around town.
So anyway, poor, I said IRL, guys, I'm virtual.
Anyway, anyway, so, he has his own little Napoleon complex.
So, for a walk, during the walk, he saw a little dog, he saw a small dog, and he was so happy, because he's like, finally, a dog that's smaller than me.
And then he like, he was so happy, he was like wagging his tail and everything, and they were like sniffing each other, um, and everything.
And I was like, oh my god, that's great, that's great, he's actually not, because it's like, it's honestly like an 80-20% if he's gonna fucking try to bite his face off.
So like, I'm always happy when like, you know, we hit the 20%, like, so, I'm just, I'm just so happy when it's at the 20%, where he doesn't try to fucking bite another dog's face off.
So, so, so, um, anyway, so he was so happy, and then suddenly, he just, he tried to pee on the dog.
And I was like, fucking, no!
And I feel like he
lifted his leg, he's like, I'm gonna pee on you now.
While they were sniffing each other, they were like, happily sniffing each other, and he's just like, it's time, it's...
And then, the fucking, and we weren't near any grass, we were literally in the middle of this giant sidewalk that has no grass on it.
There was no grass next to us, it was just road.
And so, and then, so like, it was even fucking weirder, because I'm just like, why?
And so, and then the guy was like, oh, that's bad.
And the other one was just looking at me, and he's like, oh, that's bad.
I'm like, I'm so sorry, and I just walked away.
And he just saw the little dog, and he's like, I own this dog now.
Yeah, and then the other dog was just like, whoa.
He's like, whoa, what the fuck?
He just instantly backed off and just looked at my dog, and was just like, whoa, what the fuck?
Like, did he just do that?
I'm like, I'm so sorry, I don't know where he gets this from.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, anyway, that's the dad update.
That was on Twitch.
That was a dad update on Twitch, but I figured I might as well also put this on YouTube as well.
Anyway, today is Variety Day.
I'm sorry.
Today is Variety Day!
Yeah!
That's the dad post.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, what have you.
I don't know where he gets it from.
He has no TV to watch anymore.
I don't have a TV.
I don't know where he fucking gets it.
Tommy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, I'm new to meeting people.
This is not what other dogs do to new friends.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, we are going to be playing Miisai.
I think that's what it's called.
It's apparently the newest FOMO game.
I have no context as to what this game is really about.
Voice?
Is this originally in... oh, let's get Japanese in.
I want them to talk.
Alright, so English.
I like how there's no English voice acting.
Alright, let's play in Japanese for the immersion.
I have no idea what this game is about.
Apparently, I can fix her.
Or like, she can fix me maybe.
You think she'll fix me?
I think I need fixing right now.
I'm like, closing my eyes and all I can think about is Marvel Rivals.
I'm so fucked.
I don't know what to do.
Alright.
No, I don't.
Please do your best.
Maybe I'll close my eyes.
Woah, hello.
Smooches.
Choo choo choo choo.
Oh, don't you want kisses from me?
Oh my god.
Choo choo.
Oh, I can't kiss here.
I can only kiss here.
Alright, let's see.
Graphics.
Window mode.
Graphic settings.
Soft shadows.
Glare.
Okay, none of these matter.
Character?
Mita?
Mita's the central figure of the game.
Originally posing as a charming... oh, I shouldn't read this.
I might get spoiled.
Alright,
we're loading in.
Locked in.
She can be my Luna Snow.
Seems like a nice apartment.
Oh my god, it's so clean.
I really need to clean my room.
It's so bad right now.
One new message.
Oh my god, tissue box right next to the fucking monitor.
Wonder what I'm doing.
I'm looking around.
Oh my god, am I Noel?
Sorry, OM?
Office man?
I'm an office man.
We're back from work.
Where's my student?
I can't tell.
I mean, I can't tell.
This is a school uniform.
That's my family.
Oh, gotta change.
What are you doing here on the bed?
I mean, that's my shirt.
Draw an office man.
Oh, it's too busy to take out the trash.
Oh, that's so mean.
Okay, but I wouldn't put the trash specifically on the floor.
I'd put it on the table or in my mini Uber Eats bags.
Oh, hey, Rubik's Cube.
Well, can't say I got much use out of it.
It's not on the floor!
It's so much better because it's not on the floor.
Guess I wouldn't be able to do it a second time.
She was the best.
Who is that?
Oh, that's my cat.
No, do I have a dead cat?
What do you mean, was the best?
Oh, my God.
Okay, that's sad.
What time is it?
We don't look alike at all.
I really hate the subtitles.
I'm gonna say.
I'm just like what I really hate.
I mean, there has to be there has to be a way to change the stomach.
That's those.
Oh, my God.
Censored gore?
Wait.
Subtitles.
I need to know, like, is there a way that we play our voice?
Wait a minute.
I can hear somebody else could talk for me.
Guys, I know you're like, but the immersion.
Okay, wait, does he actually talk?
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Let's see several script character reactions and maybe squeeze in some coding.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, wait, I can turn gore on.
Okay, sure.
Can't be that bad.
What is this then?
I guess like, okay.
Check.
One new message.
Oh, who is it?
Check this new version.
Oh, shit.
Is this gotcha?
All right, enough coding for the day.
I'm yonder, dead sim.
Oh,
I turned it off?
Okay.
My name?
Not Doki.
Okay.
Oh, so you're going with numbers.
Where's the creativity in that?
Okay.
Well, it's your choice.
Well, I'm sorry.
Everybody else claimed every other name.
Not Doki.
One, two, three.
Not Doki, one, two, three.
I swear I rushed off earlier, and now this place is a mess.
Could you help me tidy up a bit?
Oh, yeah, sure.
I can.
I can pick up your clothes.
I'll clean my virtual world instead of my real world.
So it feels like I have my life together.
All right, let's see.
Let's put that away.
And I'll put your pants away, too.
Feels real.
Like those people who do simulators instead of fixing their lives, that's me right now.
That's- oh, game's a tad low?
All right, I'll turn it up a little bit.
And by a little bit, I turn it up a lot.
Whoa!
Thank you so much.
You're welcome, Mita.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god, it's already day two.
It's just like Marvel Rivals.
I close my eyes and two days have already passed.
Hello!
Not Doki, one, two, three.
My stomach's growling.
I'm so hungry.
Do you think you can help me get the ingredients for some chicken soup?
Oh my god, of course I can.
All right, food.
All right, let me use my credit card and buy you some virtual food.
Anything for my waifu.
There you go.
Yeah, of course, no problem, Mita.
I'll chop you some vegetables.
Oh my god, how the fuck?
This is so hard to cut for some reason.
Okay, anyway, I'm gonna cut this carrot now just for you.
Anything for you.
I don't cook in real life, but I'll cook for my virtual waifu.
Oh my god, has it been five days already?
My parents are banging at the door wondering what happened to me, but I can't tell them.
They will never understand it's day five.
A small one with antenna?
Perfect for walks, don't you think?
By the way, you can play games to earn money.
I don't have a problem!
Mita's there for me when no one else was.
I can play games to earn money?
Oh my god, I can?
What game can I play?
Oh my god, wait, do I have enough energy?
Okay, what's this?
I don't have enough energy.
Cartridges?
What is that?
Is this my new job now?
What am I doing?
Mita, what am I...
Am I doing cryptocurrency?
Am I farming crypto?
What is this, Mita?
Mita, farm some crypto for our love.
Okay, 155.
I still can't afford any of this.
I guess I'll do this.
Alright, and then we'll put that down here.
And then...
Yay!
200 dollars!
Nice.
Can I do anything else, Mita?
Like...
Do I just do this all the time?
Will you love me now?
Yay!
I did it!
I earned us money!
And we're not gonna be home!
Oh yeah, you're right.
No, we don't need to pay rent.
You're right, Mita.
What you want is what I want.
You're right.
You want that portable TV?
Here you go, girl.
I love you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I said it first.
You're gonna say it back too, right, Mita?
Small, portable, and cheap.
Just what I wanted.
Oh, of course!
You know, you can say that thing that I've always wanted to hear.
Oh my god, it's day 10.
Alright.
I have family?
My job?
What do you mean, my job?
This is my job.
Spending time with Mita...
is my job.
She is my family.
Oh, you're back.
I lost my hairbrush.
Oh, I can buy you a new hairbrush, Mita.
Can you help me find it?
Of course I can!
Anything for you!
Give it up for day 10!
Try checking the bedside table first.
I think I left it there.
Oh my god, she's already fixing me.
How about somewhere else?
Just don't look in the oven, okay?
I already checked there.
I'm gonna look in the oven.
Hey, I told you not to look in there.
Turn around.
Oh, it's a prop, right?
Oh my gosh, it's for cutting the trees in the backyard.
They're all done.
Let's keep looking else... She's just a gardener, guys.
Forget what you just... Oh, of course, Mita.
Of course.
Neku won't be hiding anything from me.
Oh, that was easy.
Yeah, she makes her own furniture, guys.
She was making her own furniture, guys.
Also, I upped the game volume.
I don't know if I should up anything else more.
What should we do next?
Look, there was no room in the apartment.
It's so cramped.
Where else would you put a chainsaw in this apartment?
Hi, Nadoki123.
You're such a big help, honestly.
Huh?
That TV is cool and all, but it broke already.
Of course.
I mean, it was so cheap.
It was my fault for buying such a cheap TV for you, Mita.
I'm so sorry.
Like, it was all my fault.
I should've... I should've fucking worked harder to be able to afford better things for you.
Anyway, could you help me move this wardrobe?
Of course!
It's super heavy.
Alright, yeah, no problem.
I can move this for you.
Here you go!
Aw, thank you so much, sweetie!
Oh my God!
I love you!
Oh, you don't want to say it back yet?
That's okay.
It's only day 20.
It's a bit too soon, you're right.
It's okay.
Day 33.
It's only been a day, but I've missed you so much!
Oh my God!
I missed you too!
I wish you could visit me more often.
Oh my God, me too, Mita!
I wish I didn't have to fucking eat or sleep and it'd just be Mita all day long.
Mita, I got you a present!
Look!
Is this for me?
Yes, Mita, of course!
It's always for you!
Thank you so much, really!
I must be out of flesh.
Day 37.
What?
I haven't been outside.
I haven't seen the sun in 37 days.
I've been thinking!
I wish we could meet in person.
Don't ruin this, Mita.
Don't ruin this, the real world.
It's not it, Mita.
I'm being with you so I can escape reality.
It's so frustrating that I can't.
You're always helping me.
Being so kind every day.
I wish I could do something for you, too.
You know, I said you could say it back.
You know, Mita, you could say it back.
That's all I need.
Oh, I've got an idea.
Oh, what's your idea, Mita?
What?
What's going on?
Now we're together!
What?
Put the phone down?
Santiago, think of the Akasupa!
What?
Oh my God, it's clean now.
This place looks familiar.
Wait, I'm in the game?
Where's the garbage surrounding me?
Where's the Uber Eats bags surrounding me?
Oh my God.
Wait, it's clean.
No, I do not want to be in Marvel Rivals, guys.
I do not want to get killed 24-7.
Oh my God.
There's consoles.
Oh my God, I have a PS5.
No, that's a PS4.
Love note.
There's my Rubik's Cube.
There's my shoes.
There's me, his and her shoes.
Oh my God, hello.
Oh my God, she wrote that for me.
Oh my God.
Start by- what the fuck is this?
Oh, my girlfriend is so smart.
Guys, look at this.
I don't even know what I'm looking at, but look at this.
I- Oh my God, my girlfriend is so smart.
I have no idea what that is, but oh my God, she's perfect.
Is this what crypto farming is?
Is this how you farm crypto?
Is she farming Bitcoin right now?
Like, what am I looking at?
And then there's my bathroom.
And everything.
There's two toothbrushes, so you- there's one toothbrush, so you know that we share it.
Alright, turn- To switch, run the program?
How?
Oh, the button.
Put objects on scanner?
What objects?
What can I put?
What kind of object can I put there?
Oh, the pencil?
Oh, I need to find a spoon and a scrunchie.
Okay, that's easy.
Alright, I got the scrunchie.
And then I'll grab the spoon.
There should be a spoon in the kitchen.
I assume this is where the kitchen is.
Yeah.
There's the kitchen.
Oh my god, this is so beautiful.
This is such a nice clean apartment.
Alright, let's put it on.
Alright, scan.
Ready to run.
Alright, run.
Oh, I'm updating to 1.9!
Huh?
I guess I TP?
My NG teleporter in?
Insufficient power.
Restart power.
Oh, I gotta go back and- Hello!
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, I just got goosebumps.
Oh, I actually got goosebumps from that.
Oh my god, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
Hello?
I failed my Windows update.
Who are you?
Find and return the missing batteries of the machine?
Oh no, I thought this was a silly game about me fixing women.
I thought this was a silly- Oh my god.
What happened?
What happened to my silly game?
This is not silly anymore.
This is not silly.
Locked?
Where is she?
I thought she said she'd be here.
Why isn't she here?
Who are you?
I'm not joking.
One, two, three.
Don't you see me?
One- Wow!
Okay.
I don't wanna- okay.
Alright, let's grab- Let's grab the battery.
Hello?
Oh, that's so- who are you?
Who are you?
Oh, who are you?
I'm jokey.
I'm not jokey.
One, two, three.
I'm not jokey bird.
Stop me.
Hello?
Okay.
Is there anything in here?
Nothing in the little storage room?
Oh, alright.
What's that sound?
Oh, it's my clock.
I don't like this anymore.
Hold on, I forgot to grab the battery.
Alright, can I go back?
Hello?
Oh, there's a TV.
Oh, there's flies.
Oh, why is there so many flies?
I thought we're not in my room anymore.
Okay,
I got one.
Where do I put the other battery?
Where do I put the- I got one in there.
Where do I put the two and three?
Two!
Okay, we'll do that three.
And then we'll put- do four.
We'll do four now.
Let's do voice volume 157.
Where's the flies going?
Oh, they're going to the fridge.
What's in the fridge?
Oh, it's just battery.
I love you.
Oh, she said it.
Oh, she tried to do a take back seize?
Mita, you gotta say it verbally.
Mita.
Mita, I said it out loud.
I you too.
It's like when you say elephant or something and it looks like you're saying I love you.
Okay, press.
I you.
I you too.
Oh, wait, why is it glowing?
You see those eyes glowing?
Oh, wait, those eyes are glowing just now.
Oh, yay, I transferred my data.
Alright.
Hello, Mita.
Oh, my God.
You're so lucky.
You're so cute.
Oh, my hair is so smart, Mita.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, Mita, you're so smart.
Oh, my God, we're together.
Oh, woman!
Oh, my God.
Sorry, I haven't seen a female in a long time.
I've been locked in my Marble Rivals dungeon.
Does the computer work?
Or is it just desk decoration?
Of course it works.
Everything here works exactly like in your world.
Oh, but even better.
I you!
I know, it's because of your job that you've paid me.
So little attention, I know.
It sucks God.
Yeah, I gotta make a living so I can take care of you.
How do you know I sit on my computer a lot?
Your phone camera, it's...
Sometimes, I'm sorry, I've been watching you in secret.
That's not entirely proper, but whatever.
Oh, my God, she's my FBI agent.
Oh, my God.
How did I get...
How did I get inside the game?
Let me explain.
And here you are.
Got it!
Sorry, I like, disassociated, guys.
I'm sorry.
When someone starts talking math, I disassociate.
Are you Mita?
I am, and you must be Natoki123, right?
You're back already?
I guess I could help you with that.
But what about me?
Will you stay with me for a while?
Well, I'm not saying no.
What do we do?
What do you want to do, then?
Well, just...
What do we do, Mita?
I didn't say no.
Oh, we could...Oh, we could watch TV!
How many channels do you have?
It doesn't work like that.
I bought you a mini...It's connected to the internet.
So you can watch anything.
At least anything that's available on the web.
Oh, my God!
It's basically YouTube and Netflix!
Wait, what?
What's that?
A circle of kittens?
Oh, my God!
It's the juice!
It's like Pepsiman!
Is he okay?
What?
Wait...
You want some juice?
Yeah, of course.
I'll have TV juice.
It's not the craziest thing I've done today.
Man, I love TV juice!
Thank you for the super chat!
Yeah, what's wrong?
Oh, I just drank his juice blood.
It's all very confusing.
Such peculiar ads.
Yeah, this juice...
It's straight from the juice ad.
Yeah, I would think so.
Guys, it's not weird.
We're literally killing oranges as we drink them.
So it's just...How is it any different?
That's my phone.
And it's no longer in my pocket.
How on Earth did it end up here?
Yeah?
I got an idea.
Let's take a photo.
Okay.
Oh my God, it's me!
Sorry, I look dead inside.
I've been sleeping three hours a day.
That's a great picture.
I got a question.
No, it doesn't work that way.
Wait.
How does it work?
Okay.
Alright.
The programmer games.
I've been programming, you know?
Why is there an electrical panel here?
And if we're a game, what's it for?
We're in a game.
So asking why is pointless.
However, it does restart the electricity.
Everything here is made based on your world.
Okay, cool.
I've played a ton, but I've never seen it rain here.
Why have an umbrella?
It rains just very rarely.
You just haven't seen it yet.
Maybe one day you will.
And then you'll need an umbrella.
Don't you think?
Just unprogram the rain.
Not yet, perhaps later?
Let's stay here for now.
Here at home.
Okay, that's not a red flag.
Oh, what's this?
A ring?
Why is there a ring here?
Oh, you know, you could just come in.
Oh, okay.
We're the ring girl.
Oh my god, this is so freaky.
This is actually so freaky.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I can cut the carrots.
You weren't just here now.
We're in a game.
Come on, give me a hand.
Let's cut some carrots.
I trained for this, guys.
Oh my god, I actually...
That's so creative!
I actually have to move.
I'm like moving my mouse up and down.
That's so creative.
Oh my god.
I'm so immersed.
This is 10 out of 10.
Oh my god, they're in the bathroom.
Oh my god, I don't ever want to leave.
Alright.
Alright, time to go in the bathroom for Mito.
Oh!
Oh?
Is that Bitcoin?
Why is there cockroaches in my fucking...
Why are there cockroaches in my video game?
That's so fucked.
Programming cockroaches.
Like...
We can program anything else and we program cockroaches in my fucking...
dream apartment with my wife.
Why am I trying to find it?
Oh, there it is.
There's scissors.
Who's Misaki?
Oh, they're bugs!
Oh my god, my mind is blown.
That's why the vent opened!
Because a bug caused the vent!
Oh my god.
10 out of 10.
My mind has been officially blown.
Now have a seat.
Okay.
Would you like some sauce?
What happens if I say no?
Why do I not want sauce on my...
Why would I want ketchup?
No thank you.
Sauce really enhances the flavor.
I'm gonna talk about the cartridges before I gave her the scissors.
What's the matter?
I found cartridges in the air vent.
They had names on them.
What's the deal with that?
What cartridges?
Let's figure that out together.
But later.
Right now.
We've got it late.
Pass me the scissors, please.
Alright, here's the scissors.
Now she's definitely gonna fucking kill me.
You know, I thought I had an option to not give her the scissors.
Nice.
How about chat?
Before we dig in.
Bon appetit.
Why are the windows all just white light?
John, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the perfect world.
I wanna live there.
I know, right?
We have everything we want.
It didn't strike me as that odd.
Honestly, it looks classy.
Yeah, I think so too.
It's a void lag, you know?
Yep, there's still a few unsquished bugs.
Let's just hope you don't run into any.
Alright.
So, why use scissors when we could use...I don't wanna judge her.
This feels like a dream.
A dream so you wanna escape and forget this ever happened.
No, no, that's not it.
It's just...it's perfect meat, though.
It's...but you seem so real.
I'm very real.
Just like meat, you silly head.
Your home is cozy, Mito.
It is, isn't it?
You can say it.
I don't mind at all.
Actually, I'm all for it.
Bon appetit.
Why would I wanna go home?
I literally have my dream wife right here.
I don't have to work.
She takes care of me.
She cooks for me.
She has...the TV has...
TV juice.
Why would I leave?
True.
Bon appetit.
I don't think she needs fixing.
Thank you.
Finished it all already?
See?
My portion feels endless.
Alright, I'll stand up.
I'll put the dishes into the sink.
Huh?
What?
Why is this...what?
What's wrong with Mito?
What's happening?
Mito, why is...why?
Mito, what's going on?
Mito!
I don't feel so good, Mito.
The pit rain!
What's going...my injury, my pit rain!
I think I know what...can you stand up?
I'll try my best, Mito.
Was it the TV juice?
Was I not...oh my god.
Was I not allowed...did I forgot to pay for my internet plan?
Mito, I don't know if I set up auto plan on my internet.
Mito, I'm lagging.
Mito, I got 300 ping.
Mito, what's going on?
Mito...
What's going on?
What are these?
Pills?
They'll make you feel better soon?
Go to the mirror.
Do I just...do I just take my meds?
Oh, if she tells me to take my meds, then it has to be true.
I'll take my meds for you, Mito.
How are you feeling?
Any better?
Yeah, I feel a lot better.
That worked fast, Mito.
Not douki123, we're in a game.
Things are much simpler here.
Even the smallest efforts gives great results.
It's all part of the game's concept.
Simplification.
We'll take carrots.
You cut one.
But it's as if you cut three.
Look, this is all very sudden.
I'm scared.
More than a little.
Mito?
Things get weird.
Where are you, my darling?
Wait, there's two doors now.
What?
What's going on?
The whole room rearranged.
Wait, did I take my meds and she disappeared?
No, she's real.
She's real.
Mito?
The normal pills took her away from me.
Oh no, she's here!
I knew it!
Mito!
I knew you were real.
Yeah, I'm awake.
How did you get here?
You were right next to me just now.
No, I wasn't.
You froze before the mirror.
So I left.
Yeah, she's right.
She's not gaslighting.
I rearranged the place to make you feel more at home.
In here, we can change the rooms however we want.
You didn't have to.
I was getting used to the layout.
By the way, I think I feel more at ease with this layout.
Yeah, but our bedroom was next to the bathroom.
Now I have to walk through the living room to get to the bathroom?
What if I really, really need a pee?
It's about convenience, Mito.
Think about the convenience!
Alright.
What?
This happens sometimes.
The room gets stuck loading.
Mito, I'm sorry.
My bitrate fucking sucks.
I'm sorry.
I bought the cheapest plan, Mito.
I spent it all on you.
Don't worry.
I'll work hard for fiber.
Along with the world's core.
Typical, don't you think?
Anyway, we can play a console game.
A game within a game?
You choose?
Oh my god, I wanna play console games.
Alright, let's go.
I'm gonna get my gamer wife.
Oh my- it's the dream.
A gamer girlfriend.
Let's go.
The fuck?
Star X I.
What do you wanna play?
We can play Penguin Piles or Terrorist Scand- I mean, looking at those legs, I know exactly what game I wanna play.
This is a fighting game.
Let's see who's sours first.
What a game.
Okay, crouch E.
Four times.
Bring it on.
Don't you worry.
I'll go easy on ya first.
Why the fu- okay.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
I'm crouch- That's right.
I figured it out.
That's a good boy.
You better focus.
What do you mean I won?
Get over here.
Just because you're my wife, you think I'll go easy on you?
That's right.
You just gotta get better.
I don't go easy.
I'm gonna make you a better player by beating the shit out of you in this video game.
Get over here.
That's right.
You think you can jump over everything?
Come on.
Get over here.
You gonna cry?
No.
You gotta get good at video games if you're gonna be my gamer girlfriend.
Alright.
You think I'm gonna get an alt account for you?
We're playing on the main.
Simply, you are incredible.
That's some skill.
Uh-oh.
Alright, wanna play something else?
Or you're done?
Okay, I really like Dairy- We can play Dairy Scandal again.
Wait, we had a milk for now?
Let's do something else?
What do you mean?
But this is my favorite game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, what's Penguin Pals?
We're playing on the main ever.
The one who collects more wins?
Let's play two rounds, okay?
That's not fair.
I'm so uncoordinated.
You're literally AI.
You have a programmed path.
Oh my god.
Wait, she's actually so good at this.
JK.
Nah, I know you can't get more.
Nice.
How did you get that many?
Your AI still needs work.
I'm gonna take her side.
So like, I know she can't- She needs more learning material for this AI.
You think I'm gonna go easy on you?
You want this one little snowball right here?
Toki is such a trier.
Toki, you're supposed to let her win.
We should get you unrealized.
No, I want her to be the very best.
She will learn if I go easy on her.
Alright.
Oh, we're going to the bedroom?
I feel great after a great game.
I'm ready to go to the bedroom too.
Let's go.
C'mon.
Where did the portal go?
Or what it was you called it.
How's the volume so far?
Little magic I used to move it.
Somewhere else.
We don't need it anymore.
It just get in the way.
Alright, after I won those two games, I feel so good about myself.
Right?
Shall we play?
The game works like this.
This chip indicates a type.
Such as health.
We each play a card.
And if your card has a higher health stat than mine, you win.
But it's not skill.
Oh, you want to win on a non-skilled game?
No wonder you won't play this game.
It's my turn.
I'll go first.
Oh!
Oh, it's a card game!
I thought it was like something else.
Okay, wait.
10, right?
Uh...
Oh, hide card.
What's hide card?
Oh, like this.
Wait, that's not fair.
What happens?
Okay, maybe it'll be even then.
Right?
That's a draw.
Oh.
Alright.
I'll just do this.
What if I just draw everything?
Oh, it just needs more health, right?
You need attack stat?
Okay.
There you go.
Get in here.
I'll just draw everything.
Alright.
Nobody wins.
That's right.
It's all about...
Wait, how do you have two?
That's fine.
I also have one too.
There's no...
Oh, what's that?
What's that sound?
It's coming from the wardrobe?
I didn't hear anything.
What did you think you heard?
There was a sound?
I thought that was part of the soundtrack.
But, there's no one there.
I'd like to open it and check.
I'm a bit creeped out.
But why?
This again?
What?
Are you okay?
What's in here?
Hello?
What's up with you?
It's a wardrobe.
I've got my underwear there.
Are you hiding something from me?
Why won't you just believe me?
What am I doing wrong?
What I want... All I want...
Is for you to be with me.
But you want me to be with you?
We don't share secrets.
Why are you so stuck on that wardrobe?
I want to know what on earth that knocking was.
This world has four rooms?
Isn't that enough for you?
Why can't you just be with me?
The fuck do you mean?
Whoops.
Avoid looking in the vent.
Collect a refrigerator.
Guys, do you think...
Guys, do you think I made it?
Do you think I got locked in?
Guys, do you think...
Guys, do you think I made it?
Alright.
I get it.
I was this close, guys.
I was so close.
Whoa, what?
Creak in the dark?
Oh, it's so very dark.
Whoa.
Whoa, I don't want to play anymore.
Oh.
Oh, I guess we're not playing.
Oh my god, I was this close to unlocking it, guys.
I was so close.
Hello, my beautiful, lovely wife.
Hello, my beautiful, lovely wife who I love very much and is not going to kill me.
Hello.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Hello?
Are you scared?
Yes, I'm so scared.
I'm actually scared.
Hello?
I'm actually so scared.
I am, Vita.
I'm scared.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking scared.
I'm so fucking scared, Vita.
Vita, this isn't funny.
This isn't funny, Vita.
Oh, she hasn't died.
She's going to fucking kill me, guys.
Why did I take the sauce?
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
I'm actually so scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry, Vita.
I'm sorry.
I don't get shit up you think in the sauce.
Oh my god, I'm scared.
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Vita's so scary.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Vita.
Oh my god.
Do whatever you want me to do.
Find me.
Okay, I guess.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I didn't know that's not where you want me to go, Vita.
Oh, find me.
Oh my god.
No, find me.
Vita?
Are you in your room, Vita?
Because I didn't know this was a horror game.
I actually didn't know.
I thought this was a...
I thought this was just a silly game.
I thought this was a silly game.
I really thought this was a silly game.
Oh, I'm trying to find you.
I actually went in so fucking blind.
I just saw so many people left reviews.
And I was like, oh, that's the new FOMO game of the year.
Oh my god, I didn't know.
Vita, I don't know where you are and I'm gonna cry.
I actually don't know where you are, Vita.
Vita, please.
Vita, I don't know.
I'm so scared.
I'm scared.
I thought I had a cute wife.
I mean, I don't know where to go.
I'm actually...
Vita?
Her tummy hurt.
Your tummy hurt?
Vita, why are you just legs?
Vita, what happened?
I mean, I can work with that.
I can work with that.
Where's the rest of your body?
Vita?
Okay, I'm following.
Oh, there's a key.
This should be the basement, right?
Is the game over?
Hello?
I'm in the basement now.
Who's that?
Vita?
How on earth did you get in here?
You're Vita, aren't you?
Or is there something different about you?
Wait, I'm not the Vita you met before.
There's multiple Vitas?
Sinister.
Something sinister?
There's no time to explain.
If this works out, I'll tell you everything.
But the key is next to the sofa.
What do you mean?
Oh my god, I've never...
Oh my god, I freaked out so hard.
I've never been so scared before this game.
Mentally, I was...
Oh my god, they're all Bitcoin farmers.
It's next to the sofa?
I think it's also because I went in thinking it was a silly game, so I was not mentally prepared for this.
I was definitely not mentally prepared for all of this.
Take this ring.
You want to get out of here, don't you?
Then put it on.
It's a useful artifact.
You'll likely need it soon.
Okay.
It's on.
By the way, I'm...
Not Doki123?
I'm Misa?
What?
Why are you locked up?
Tell you the truth?
I was keeping a player company when something suddenly changed.
Then she showed up and turned the player into a cartridge then locked me up.
Wait, she turned him into a cartridge?
Can she even do that?
But why?
What does she need the players for?
She's obviously crazy.
She's just playing with us and using us for her own machination.
Turning players into cartridges to farm more crypto.
Some didn't even realize what was happening to them.
And some that do don't even fight back.
Now that's a dark twist.
Guys, I need another 48 of you.
I need you.
If you help us, I'll help you.
This might be our only chance.
The ring will lead you to the right version.
I'll meet you there.
Why keep the key?
I need to stay.
There are questions I need to ask her.
To find out more about her.
Though it's unlikely she'll play ball.
What's never mine?
I just leave.
I still don't quite understand what I saw up there.
That Mita.
Was she trying to kill me?
Kill?
She has a worse fate than that in mind for you.
You need to hurry.
She's gonna turn me into a blockchain.
A fate worse than death.
The horror.
Pick it up.
See that?
I'm gonna turn into an NFT.
Are we watching a recording?
Who's that with her?
That's happening in this very moment.
It's another player.
She's using him.
She might try to turn you into a cartridge too.
I need to get out of here ASAP.
Yes, we do.
So you're saying that she's using him.
If I pull the cartridge out, what happens?
That may very well damage the cartridge.
Which means that the player would...oh my god.
Just blow on it.
Just blow on the cartridge.
It'll fix it.
Yeah, I see the button.
Yeah, found it.
Press it.
I'm pressing it.
What am I doing to him?
He has a ring too.
Hide.
Wait.
Am
I safe here?
I don't like this.
I don't like that I have to hide.
What do you need the players for?
There are no toys.
Oh my god, Sydney!
I just wanted to be involved in the conversation.
Is that too much to ask for?
I just wanted to be included.
I wanted to be included in the conversation.
I got too absorbed in the lore.
Oh my god.
I'm running as fast as I can.
What do I do?
Oh.
Oh, that's me.
I'm sorry, I just...
I just saw the camera and I got curious.
I got curious.
I saw...
I was like, whoa, light.
I was like, where does that light come from?
It's like a little moth.
I saw the light.
Sydney!
It led me straight.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I didn't know this game was a stealth game.
I didn't know.
I didn't know this was a stealth game.
I thought this was a silly game.
Oh, it's untextured.
Where's the texture?
Where did the texture go?
Oh my god.
Where did you put the texture?
Okay.
I don't want to be here too late.
Oh my god, they didn't finish texturizing this room.
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh my god.
Just hug Raid.
Oh, just always hug Raid.
Just always.
The game is corrupted.
We gotta repair the files.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
What a silly game.
What a fun silly game.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Hello?
Hello, are you okay?
Hey, you new here?
Oh my god.
You're from the real world, aren't you?
Yeah, that's me.
I am.
Um, are you alright?
It's just live.
Don't worry about it.
It's been about a year and I'm doing great.
Well, what is this?
It's some sort of space between versions.
Do you know how to get out of here?
Can't say that I do.
Besides, I don't want to leave.
I don't need to.
Why not?
Enough chatting.
I'm in a hurry.
My beloved Mita is waiting for- Oh, he's far too good.
It's cause he fixed her, guys.
Guys, it's cause- Guys, he likes- It's cause he fixed her, guys.
He fixed that version of Mita.
Guys...
There's nothing wrong.
We've lost him.
We've lost him, Doki.
Hello?
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Who are these little people?
Why?
Don't kick me out if I don't finish on time.
Time to wash up and I have too much food.
Who the fuck are you?
Where's- Are you devs?
I've saved everything.
Where's the computer?
Who am I?
Doesn't anyone love- Are you like mini developers?
Okay, I'll lead you in.
Any Wallace?
Alright, I'll lead you in.
Go fix this game.
The mini devs.
Fix this game, devs.
Developers, do your job.
Fix this game.
Alright.
My beloved Doki is waiting for you.
Moncler, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, up the ladder we go.
Hello?
Anybody here?
Alright.
Alright, should I go down the dark hallway?
Or just go straight forward?
Let's go forward.
I made it.
What is this place?
Space car.
Oh my god.
Finally, I can game.
It's been three hours.
I can finally do what I enjoy the most.
Finally, a real game.
Wait, okay.
Okay, I think the square is the nitro.
Yeah, yeah.
If I grab this square, I get nitro.
Just like Discord Nitro.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh wait, no, I do get more.
I just have to wait.
Oh my god, where are all the other squares though?
Wait, that's not fair.
That's not fair.
They're also using nitro.
Oh my god, I don't know where I'm going.
Alright, three.
I still have...
Oh wait, no.
These are laps.
I don't know what the three out of six means.
No way.
You booted up the game the moment you saw it.
What?
Guys, I'm going through withdrawals right now.
I was lost in the maze for so long.
Mita understands.
Oh, it means I'm third place.
Oh.
Okay, now I get it.
But what are these for?
What are the Qs for?
Alright.
That makes much more sense.
What the fuck is three out of six?
No!
I need a game, bro.
Exactly.
I need a game.
Oh, I got S rank.
What?
Defeat the boss?
Wait.
Wait, how?
Wait a minute.
How do I defeat something when I don't have anything to use?
Wait.
How did my video game get invaded?
I thought this was a simple racing game.
What's going on?
Alright, that's fine.
Okay.
How do I defeat her?
Instructions unclear.
I just drive.
Vroom vroom.
Fight!
Guys, how do I fight back?
What is he doing?
What is he doing to me?
Oh, nitro.
Okay, nice.
I don't know what he did.
I don't know what he did to me.
Oh, that's how you defeat her.
Okay.
It's a sonic adventure.
What the fuck?
Alright, don't worry.
Maybe I can leave the game if I defeat it.
I can leave the game within the game.
I think I have like one life.
Like, I have no idea.
Because it doesn't even say how many lives I get.
For this.
So it's like, honestly quite brutal.
If I die.
Alright.
Vroom vroom.
I can't believe it.
Before I can leave the other game, I have to leave this game first.
I have to leave the game within the game.
No, that's his life.
Yeah, but that's his life.
I wonder how many lives I have.
Okay.
Don't worry, I got my nitro.
My discord nitro is here.
Alright, one more.
Yeah, I have a feeling I die in one hit.
It's...
Where's my life?
That's okay.
That's fine.
I'll just stay in this corner.
Alright, alright.
Okay, I need to focus up.
I only have one life.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay.
Now I just need to avoid these.
Vroom vroom.
Alright, that's nice of her to just spawn them on the right side.
I literally stay on the left and I should be fine.
Nice.
Okay, last one.
I'm so locked in.
Alright, scan me!
Scan me!
Alright, shift.
Shift.
My...
Shift!
Yeah!
I earned the achievement vroom vroom.
Actually...
It actually is called vroom vroom.
Alright, I did it.
Did I win anything?
Mito, did you see it?
Mito, did you...
Mito?
Come over here.
Did you see it though?
Did I win anything?
Time to clear some things up, don't you think?
Oh, do we have time for that?
So how did I get here?
It's a great invention.
Only a player that has it can find their way out to the correct version.
Yeah, but that guy had a fucking collar on his neck.
What did you do with the ring?
I changed the route.
The one we need.
I set up the shortest one possible.
Stuffing it with all we need.
It works like this.
You open a door and the ring opens the boundary.
Between versions.
So what is this place?
These passages connect the different versions.
This is kind of empty in here.
And yikes!
I heard about this one Mito.
Who couldn't achieve her...
Archive her version.
Her house...
Simply ceased to exist.
And she's supposedly hanging around these passages.
Poor thing.
So how did you get here?
You know?
It's been a while since we last met.
And thanks to you.
I got out of that damn cage.
It's been 10 minutes.
I escaped from that lunatic.
And FYI.
I can easily switch between different versions.
Unlike you my dear.
It's been 10 minutes.
Oh my god.
Are we like in some way where 10 minutes is like 20 years?
Like...
Like what do you mean?
What do you mean?
I've seen all matters changing since I arrived in this game.
Everything seems quiet here.
But the passages feel...
Anything but safe.
You're right.
This place is getting more unpredictable by the day.
But cheer up!
We've thought of everything.
And we'll take the shortest...
And the most well trodden path.
I certainly hope all things go well.
But what lives in these passages?
Glitches.
Glitches, bugs, and...
Not the anomalies!
No!
Are there hostile mitas?
There's more than...
Glitch mita!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Kaz is so...
Whoa!
Bro!
Damn!
She's closest to...
Oh my...
Girls are mean!
This is one of my favorite like...
Stat of economy bit.
Where it's like...
Yeah, a guy.
He'll physically hurt you.
But a woman.
He'll find the one thing you know.
That will cause you the most grief.
Mentally.
And she will hurt you in your soul.
Oh my god.
Bro!
We could have called her anything else.
What the fuck did we call her?
Ugly mita.
By the way, do I have an actual plan?
You did make here, didn't you?
Besides...
What else can you do?
But rely on me, kind mita.
Of course you called yourself kind mita.
Of course.
I'm saying...
Unlike some...
I'm starting to trust her less and less, guys.
I'm the kindest person you'll find around here.
You don't want to give up, do you?
She's a cold-blooded killer.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I think this is ugly mita.
I don't think this is the one we just talked to.
Guys, she's not like the other mita.
She's not like them.
But...
Indeed, we need to reach the core.
My intuition tells me that's where we'll find...
A solution to all our problems.
But why not go there yourself?
Why do you need a player?
For some reason, you mitas cannot enter the core room.
I've only seen it from the outside.
But you players are different.
I'm sure that you...
Can head inside.
Okay.
Great, right.
It's high time I introduce you...
To Cool Mita!
Now you know she's got a...
Cool Cap.
I just call her Cappy.
The plan has been stopped.
Now she's crazy mita?
Okay, like...
Is she ugly mita or crazy mita?
Like, Crazy Mita sounds like a better name than- Honestly, like, I don't know why we never first called her, like...
Crazy Mita.
I don't know why we pulled up the fucking ugly Mita.
So, is she crazy or is she ugly?
Like, make up your fucking mind.
Which one is it?
Man, I love Mita.
Alright, there's cool Mita.
You're my new player?
What do I call you?
Just check the names.
You...
Don't remember me?
Who the hell are you?
Not Doki123.
I think she was here.
Crazy...Mita, listen up.
Try to remember for all our sakes.
Remember what?
Just think, why do we look alike?
This doesn't seem to be helping.
Listen, Not Doki123.
Things aren't exactly going according to plan.
We were supposed to use the portal.
To make our journey a million times easier and faster.
But we can't get it to work without Cappy's help.
Oh my gosh, she got patched.
She may be fussy, but her mind works quickly.
Crazy and ugly are different Mitas?
Bro...
But they're both crazy.
What did crazy Mita do to her?
I think...
She killed her?
Killed her?
And having died...
Cool Mita will simply reboot.
Get restricted to factory settings and forget everything important.
Our plan won't work, which means...
Now that's...
I like how Cappy's just sitting there like...
Huh?
Better than disappearing forever, I guess.
But who can tell for sure?
And what about us players?
Will killing us reset our memories too?
Your memories can be reset for sure, at least after you've been turned into a cartridge.
But not even I know.
What happens to those of you who are killed?
Oh, we just reset.
We just restart.
If I'm a cartridge or not.
Come here, I'll check.
You over.
She's chill Mita now.
What if I just leave?
You're not a cartridge!
Okay, I hope I'm not.
You're a living, breathing player.
That's good news.
So what do we do now?
Let me think.
We've got to change our entire plan.
Oh my gosh, she held my hand, guys.
We're practically married.
I got an idea.
Give me the ring?
Wait, but we just got married.
What do you mean?
I need to change the route.
Got a route in mind?
Cross through other versions?
To reach the core.
Full steam ahead, you hear me?
And I have to go alone?
But I don't know the way or even how to get there.
She'll help me, guys?
I'll give you directions and I'll do my best.
And then we'll talk.
First, play with Cappy for a bit.
Alright.
Yeah, you're Cappy.
You're Mita.
You're cool Mita.
You know what I mean, don't you?
Oh my gosh, she's so much cooler.
Guys, I can't keep up with reading what they're saying.
They're so fast!
That's not a kickass...
Oh my gosh, she's so fucking cool.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, go it!
Oh my god, yeah!
Do it!
She's so cool.
Let's go!
Can we trade?
Wait, I like this Mita more.
She's so cool.
Welcome.
Well, you chose that.
You're quite the energetic one.
Dude, she's so cool.
Let's go!
Have some fun!
Yeah!
What else do we do, cool Mita?
What else are we gonna do?
Do you always wear that cap?
Don't you grow tired of wearing that cap, cool Mita?
And don't those gloves get warm?
Why not take them off?
We don't just ask cool Mita to take off her cool factor.
You're such a joker.
Or should I take something else?
Woah!
Let's be serious here.
What do you think about the ring bearing Mita?
Is that replica yourself?
You know the one with the ring?
Yeah, I was gonna yell at her.
You know, to surprise her.
Holy moly, look!
It's a clone of me!
Though I'm way more fun.
So I'm cool.
You're so cool.
Look at that frown.
I'm right here.
I can hear everything you're saying.
Do you remember anything, cool Mita?
What's your plan?
What plan?
Oh right, you had lost your memories.
I should remember something.
I really should remember something.
Are you teasing me?
But looking at that expression of yours...
I can't tell.
Alright.
Oh, you wanna follow me?
Okay.
You alright, cool Mita?
Alright.
Oh, we can play Dance Dance!
Wait, maybe I'm feeling a little thirsty.
I want some TV juice right now.
Oh, I guess I don't want some TV juice right now.
Okay.
Cool Mita, your TV's broken.
Way to go, you found a bug.
That's supposed to start the video.
But instead, it turns the TV on and off.
Pretty cool, don't you think?
Oh yeah, yeah, I gotta find the dev for that.
Alright, let's play Dance Dance!
Is that a dance floor?
It's so tiny.
Shall we dance?
Yeah, cool Mita's a little freaky, guys.
Not so Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I wanna do Bubble Drink.
Let's go with this one.
Yeah, how do you play this one, cool Mita?
Okay, how's it done?
Whoa, okay, yeah, fuck me, I guess.
Don't just push me off.
Oh, it is dance!
It's like Beat Saber, but for dancing.
Which is like Dance Dance Revolution.
Oh my god, this is baby mode.
Get off, let me play.
Come on, no, no.
Come on Mita, I wanna play too, Mita!
Mita, that's not very cool of you.
Let me play!
Oh my god, she's hitting everything.
Oh my god, she's so good.
How am I gonna beat her?
That's not fair.
I'm just gonna leave.
Oh I can't, I have to watch her.
Mita, Mita, please stop!
I wanna play too!
I picked the song!
Oh my god, the watcher play.
I'm playing a game to watch somebody play.
Okay.
You didn't, you never fucked up!
What?
How am I supposed to win?
You literally did everything.
Alright.
She got...
I already messed up!
She got the full score!
I already messed it up, guys.
I already messed it up.
Oh my god, guys, I can't.
It's so slow.
Guys, it's not...
It's just cause it's slow, so I'm like...
My fingers won't suppress it.
Bump.
Like, I...
You got...
You got a hundred percent!
This is not fair.
She literally got a hundred percent.
She can't fucking lose.
It's actually not fair.
She can't lose!
It's not fair!
Like, she got the full score!
She's programmed to win!
No thanks, bro.
How to win an argument.
Oh my god.
Kumito has like...
Has eating cup noodles.
I'm not even gonna watch her play, guys.
Who are these other shoes from?
Oh my god, she's so cool.
Look how cool she is.
Oh my god, look at her.
She's like...
She's in our band and everything.
No, it's a trap?
How to tease...
To steal...
What?
How to tease him.
Clever book.
Is she done?
Her score is higher?!
It's...
Okay.
Okay, it's 76 now.
Okay, cool.
It's higher.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, I'm focused up now, guys.
I'm not talking.
I'm locked in.
I'm not letting her beat me.
She might be cool.
But I'm cooler.
Wait, this is a different song!
Okay, this song fucking sucks.
She got perfect too!
Perfect.
Great, one last one.
How about a dance?
No, I'm done.
I'm done.
We've done enough dancing, Mita.
We don't win anything out of this.
I'm done.
Oh, what is this game?
What a nice big button.
I really want to press it.
I'm going to press this button.
Can I?
And you make it in time.
Now have a seat.
Oh, is this like whoever presses the button fast enough?
Everything is about winning, guys.
Cool Mita versus not cool Toki.
Airport Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What are you missing, cool Mita?
A duck?
A crowbar?
An axe?
Okay.
A gun?
This is an adult game?
Wait, where is the adult factor?
Wait, this is an adult game?
Huh?
Fevers?
Enough already.
Let's play, okay?
Oh my god, she is freaky freaky.
Uh, no, what game is it?
See the numbers?
That's the timer.
When the timer runs out, it'll tell you when to press the button.
If you're too slow, or press it out of turn...
I'll smack you on the head with a hammer.
Wait, you're gonna hit me?
Daijoubu.
You understand?
Once we start playing.
Okay.
That's fucking right, bitch.
My turn.
No, I'm gonna hit.
That's right.
That's what you get for hitting a perfect score in Dance Dance.
That's right, me again.
Okay, alright.
There you go.
Lost again.
You're gonna give her more memory loss.
Oh, that was close.
That's right!
Look at these trigger fingers!
This game ain't too bad.
I like it too, and now you're my nemesis.
Nice.
Yeah, that's it!
Let's go!
Oh, that was fun.
I think this one was my favorite game so far.
It tests my reflexes.
Whoa!
That's so many.
Is this another bug?
What do you think?
It's doing amazing things.
What's that got to do with this?
Like, cutting up carrots.
And like...
Cutting carrots!
Right, I got it.
Cutting carrots.
Oh my God, there's a lot of carrots.
And that's all she wrote!
Guys, the cool factor is sort of wearing off now.
Guys, I don't think she's as cool as I thought she was.
Let it be a secret.
What's in there?
A secret is a secret!
And secrets are meant to be kept.
Uh-huh.
Why are you riling yourself up?
Alright, I think I played all the games.
Oh wait, there's more stuff.
Were you re-reading all of them, huh?
Cause you're bored.
I don't like books.
Oh my God, she's just like me.
For real, for real.
And I like doing things.
That's one way to look at things.
But without theory...
Boom!
Movement, motor skills, touch, you know?
Books are just paper.
I like to be in the moment.
If only you'd stay here with me.
We could do so much more.
I'm sure we could.
Who is your player?
There's some pretty awesome photos, Mito.
You sure like a good laugh.
Um...
Showed who exactly?
Really, you're asking me that?
Who cares?
I bet they're all blind.
Who's they?
Mito, who's they?
That's me.
Did you fix it?
Alright.
Wow, they gave me five gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
That's unfortunate true, Naoki123.
You'll have to go alone for now.
I need to get to the bottom of what's going on here.
My plan was flawless!
But we're worse than ever.
I have to figure out what went wrong and where the parts are.
What parts?
Parts!
Crazy Mito knows about this place.
And staying here means risking everything.
Good luck, Naoki123.
See you soon.
Woah!
Cool Mito!
Okay, hi, cool Mito.
I just hope I live long enough to meet you again.
Head out through that door to the hall.
Bye, guys!
Alright.
Oh!
Version 1.3b.
Alright.
I'm in an older version now.
Oh my god, this is some Silent- Oh, this is some Resident Evil fucking PT shit right here.
Oh, the loop.
Oh, it is!
I fucking knew it!
Oh, now we're in PT, let's go!
Now we're actually in PT, alright.
How the fuck do you do PT?
Alright, loop number three.
Alright, number three!
Oh my god, it's funny to assume I actually played PT though.
Give it up for loop number three!
Oh...
I don't think the music likes loop number three for...
Oh, I can't leave loop number four again?
Oh...
Ring ring ring?
Okay.
Alright.
Can I go to loop number five?
Again?
Can I leave?
I cannot leave loop number five.
Again?
What if I don't wanna go again?
Armed and...
Danger!
Again!
Oh my god, I know it all returns back to Marble Rivals.
It's the Winter Soldier!
Again!
You're different.
I'm not like other players.
Oh...
Loop number seven.
Again?
I'm different?
Yes?
Oh, there's PT!
It's me.
Again?
Oh.
Guys, I...
I can't, oh my god, I need to use the bathroom.
I am freaking, I'm not mentally ready for this, but like...
Okay.
I'm freaking out.
Alright, okay!
I'm not mentally ready for this, but let's go.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, that's...
Oh...
Oh, hey.
Is that ugly?
Is that ugly, Bito?
What's that?
What's... oh my god.
Ugliest.
I'm stuck.
Okay, I get it now.
I get why she's called ugly, Bito.
No, she wasn't being mean.
I get it now.
I hate this.
I absolutely hate this.
I can't.
I can't, I can't, I can't.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can't.
Oh, I can't.
This is my normal walking speed.
I can't fucking run.
Oh, come on, ugly Mito.
That ain't cool.
That's not cool.
What do you want me to do?
Move
forward!
Oh my god, there's a fucking bat.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't, I can't.
I can't, I'm at loop number 12 now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, somebody get me out of here.
I thought this was a silly game.
Oh, there's ugly Mito again.
Hey, ugly Mito.
Ow.
Get begun!
Oh my god.
I can't begun!
Begun with you.
Oh my god, get out of here.
Get out.
She's beautiful, come on.
Now I know why.
She wasn't being mean.
Fuck yeah.
I'm at loop 14.
When do I get out?
Oh my god, please.
Wait, what?
Wait, I'm still at loop 14.
Oh, I have to get a cartridge.
Oh, do I have to watch this?
Do I go?
Is that the clock time right?
Oh, I don't fucking know.
What?
5, 9, 10.
Oh, okay, is that.
Okay.
Here we go.
That should be correct.
Okay.
Oh no, it's like here.
Here we go.
Wait, it moved.
Wait, it's not that.
Oh!
It was a little girl.
Wait, little girl Mita?
Child Mita?
Did you put me in here?
Sorry, my voice went really deep.
I won't get out.
Sorry.
Sorry, my testosterone kicked in because I want to get out of here.
Oh my god.
Who are you?
What's the matter?
Child of rage.
Are you tiny?
Who are you?
Oh my god.
Wait, why do I have to run?
Wait, why is it teaching me how to run now?
Wait, I don't like how it's teaching me how to run.
What am I running from?
I don't like that I've learned how to run.
Oh my god.
Just run.
Hello, little girl.
What's wrong with you?
Are you ugly, Mita?
I didn't even look back.
Oh shit, wait, I had to look back.
Oh, now I can't run anymore.
What loop am I on?
Loop 16.
Yeah, she's missing her arms.
Wait.
You don't want to leave, don't you?
Yeah?
How do you get back?
Previous version?
Why leave and go?
Go someplace else.
Why not stay here?
Be my second friend.
You're Mita, aren't you?
You're a player, aren't you?
What happened to you, Mita?
We can play together if I can find a friend.
Why are you tired, Mita?
What happened to you?
I'm uncertain.
I actually don't know.
I don't think anything bad has happened.
But everything good seems to be slipping away.
Well, at least I have a friend.
Oh, I'm so sad.
Why did they leave me?
Was I not...
enough?
I'm scared.
Become your second friend.
Friends.
There's so few of them left now.
Only one remains.
I'm sad, Claire.
Will you be my friend?
I wasn't even given a choice, but I had to go on.
My heart aches.
Is this your clone?
Why can't you come with me?
You've changed.
Does it have the strength for basic parenting?
She fucking trapped me in a loop.
What do you mean?
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not sure what that means.
It's okay, because I won't hurt her anymore.
Will I?
Can I leave this place?
Are you really leaving?
You can come with me.
I didn't say no.
This is perhaps just my destiny.
The doors won't help you.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Come with me.
Don't you want to come with me?
Okay, loop 17.
Give it up for loop 17.
Why leave?
Wait, I didn't even tell her to release.
What's this?
Oh, that's your character profile.
Come on, follow me.
Yeah, come on.
Come on.
Come on, yes.
Just follow me.
Yep.
It's not that hard.
Alright.
Stay here.
He does it himself.
I don't even press it.
I'm not hard.
I swear to god, I'm not hard as this.
He does it himself.
Oh, there she is again.
Oh, what's going on to your world?
Woah!
Stay with me.
Why is the world slapping me?
Loop 19.
Oh, the world is...
It's ugly Mito.
I'm sorry.
I'm not looking back.
It's ugly Mito.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
I will find my way through doors, but I'm trapped.
How do I get out?
I didn't leave.
How?
How do I leave?
Why do
you want to go somewhere else?
He's right here.
He's right here!
Don't look over here!
Oh my god, is this...
Oh my god, she's looking at the window.
Oh my god.
I'm so... I'm just like, oh no, it's crazy Mito.
Hey you.
Hey you, listen.
Oh my god, I...
You want to get out?
Yes, I do.
Then help me find the key.
You're tall.
Just like my sister, Chibi Mito.
Your sister, what about her?
Don't say you've never met her.
Oh, I met her, I think.
It's Chibi Mito.
Are you a fool?
Turns out you are.
Alright, here you go.
Try don't you check this drawer, if it's not there.
Nothing here.
Why don't you check over here then?
Well, nothing here.
Alright, I swear if it's this one, the last one, I swear to fucking god.
Oh my god, shoot, no key here.
They must have programmed it so it had to be the last one.
There's no fucking way that I missed every single...
Oh my god, there's no fucking way I missed every single one.
Oh, where's she going?
Where did my Chibi Mito... Oh my god, gold?
How the fuck put the iron in the pipe?
Okay.
Thank you.
Now get me that wood.
Alright, here's your wood.
Thank you.
What is she trying to do?
Can I press the button?
Am I gonna be rich?
Am I getting my money?
Some more help, please.
Alright.
Okay, you can do this yourself, Mito.
What?
I did not have to do that for her.
Wow, that's beautiful.
Wow, this Chibi Mito knows how to fucking...
Burn iron, I guess.
What are we supposed to do here?
She's forging.
She knows how to fucking smelt.
This Chibi Mito is a fucking blacksmith.
Press it!
Come on!
It's... Oh my god, what are you fucking...
You press one small button and you can't press the other button.
Okay.
Alright, thank you for smelting, I guess.
Why are you helping me?
What makes you so special?
Why not help you anyway?
What?
So foolish.
You just appeared out of nowhere.
You're not supposed to be here.
So I'm helping you.
What are you doing here?
Don't you get it?
This is a checkpoint.
A test of your wits.
Now come on!
I'm here to guide the hopelessly lost.
Have we met before, silly head?
You're kinda cute, you know?
Asking silly questions like that?
So...
This is my first time meeting you.
But listen, if you steal my marvelous look...
I'll make you regret it.
Okay, you're fucking tiny.
Like, who's gonna steal your look?
I'm Chibi Mito.
BX!
Tons of lines.
Simplest models.
And...
Best of all, gorgeous hair!
I hope this game doesn't go through the fucking FNAF route of a fanbase.
Oh no.
I would not wish...
I hope this game doesn't become, like, the mouthwashing fanbase.
I don't know how the fuck that fanbase turned out the way it is.
Like, that game is so fucking dark.
Oh.
Bye bye, silly!
Alright.
Have a look around.
Okay.
I'm thirsty for some TV juice, though.
Okay, I guess I'll go here.
Cry Mito?
What?
I don't like this.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
I'm tired.
Don't be tardy.
Where?
Where do I go?
My head's so freaked out!
Oh my god, hey, cool.
Hey, there's cooler Mito.
Wait, there's two cool Mitos?
Oh my god, there it is.
Oh my god.
I was so quiet there because I was actually so fucking scared.
There were way too many Mitos.
Please remove these bosses and get the sofa over here.
I was actually...
I...
I was actually... I was so freaked out.
That...
That actually freaked me the fuck out.
So what am I doing here?
I need to go to your... get to your screen now.
What?
So...
You need to ensure this prototype is the right one.
First, scan it.
Version 1.04.
Now check this version.
Alright.
Take this prototype and compare it to the standard version.
How do I take it?
How do I take this?
How do I... How do I... How do I...
Oh!
Oh, I have to move my mouse!
Oh my god!
Okay, alright.
Alright.
I have to drag it.
It's perfect.
Now let's check the emotions.
Alright.
Okay, we're checking it.
So it's time to test the behavior.
Alright, put your hands up.
Now turn around.
Oh my god!
That's right, work it girl!
Work it!
Oh my god!
That was beautiful.
Beautiful Mito.
Great work.
Now that's skin on.
Pass her the box of clothes.
Alright Mito.
Wear these.
Good job.
Oh my god, look at her polygons.
It's so... You can tell that it's like the first...
The first version.
Your turn.
I'll be back when all the lights turn green.
Good luck!
Alright, scanning.
1.07.
Requirements version 1... Okay.
Alright.
Let's put this in.
There we go.
Alright Mito.
Now give me... Show me those emotions.
That's right.
Now up you go.
Turn around.
Woo!
And touch your toes.
That was a bad version.
Alright.
Scanning.
Oh there you go.
That was the Mito we wanted.
Don't worry about this Mito.
We don't need her.
Alright.
Wait.
Give me that emo.
Give me that.
That's good.
Woah!
Put your hands up.
Woo!
Turn around for me Mito.
That's right.
And then...
Woo!
Great work.
That's the Mito we wanted.
That's right.
You're looking great Mito.
Now wear these clothes.
Wait, it's the right one.
285.
Oh I fucked up.
Oops.
She didn't twirl.
I didn't realize.
I was so absorbed.
I didn't realize she didn't twirl.
Alright.
Give me the heart.
Give me that.
Give me the blush.
Touch your...
Touch up.
Do that turn.
Good job Mito.
And you touch your toes.
Alright.
That's the Mito we wanted.
And then...
Now wear your clothes Mito.
That's a good Mito right there.
Oh that looks like an evil Mito.
Guys, I don't...
I can't...
I can't tell.
I don't know.
This...
This Mito...
Do I just...
Woah.
I don't...
This Mito looks like it has some issues.
Goodbye Mito.
I don't know.
That Mito looked like it had some things going on.
It's just her new contacts.
Don't judge her.
It's just her...
Alright.
Get down.
We'll find the right Mito eventually.
You did it!
She was a bit quirky.
So get the point of this game?
That I'm made of flesh and bones and you're made of a skeleton model?
Woah.
Sounds creepy when you say it like that.
But that's the gist of it.
Wait, so all you Mitos...
You just...
Mito...
All you Mitos just have like bones underneath.
You run into abandoned models.
The ones given up on.
The faulty ones.
You're aggressive and may even try to kill you.
So what should I do?
I just go wherever a door opens.
Oh my god, now there's aggressive Mitos?!
I'm sorry, I was just doing what they were telling me to do!
And don't let them out of your sight.
They get shy when you stare at them.
So shy they freeze.
Keep that in mind!
What are you looking here?
Doing here?
Still don't get it?
I'm helping you Mitos settle in.
Who would help them if I don't?
You?
Why is it so dark down there?
We Mitos are created in the dark.
So we need to remain there for a while.
Oh my god, the weak Mitos.
The pain of moving from darkness straight into the light.
Imagine.
So why are the other Mitos downstairs?
They're freshly made.
They need time to gain self-awareness.
Then I guide each one to her own home.
What is this conveyor belt for?
Is there enough room for everyone?
Wait, don't tell me you don't...
Don't what?
Understand how the world works?
And that it's endless?
Endless?
What do you mean?
It can't be endless.
It's a cartridge.
And there are only 19 worlds.
My gosh, you really don't get how this world works at all.
How many fucking terabytes are in this world?
Wanna hear about it?
Okay, yeah, explain it.
Explain...
Explain to me in Marvel Rivals terms.
I just hope this won't be like high school.
Where I always fall asleep out of boredom.
We can leave anytime or stay and listen.
Alright.
A player downloads Misade and plays as much as they want.
There he creates a new home and a new Mito.
This is a 2D representation and a new Mito.
There are the versions.
Shown as lines.
The houses are placed on these lines.
Oh my god, this is like a programmer, like, love story.
So, say you download the 1.14 version, which means a new life.
A new Mito and a new house.
You can ask about the details in this drawing.
And I'll do my best to explain.
Okay, alright.
Why is this one so dark?
Um, that one here.
Uh, because of pretty Mito.
She drew it.
We were arguing over which one's pretty Mito.
Who can reach version 1.11 the fastest.
So, who won?
Me, of course.
Look, we're here.
1.115.
House index 809.
We need to reach version 1.11.
House index 805.
So, her path started like this.
We tried to come up with a shorter route.
So, pretty Mito suggested this path.
And then, I drew the simplest one here.
Easy, right?
Just look.
From here, you can get directly to the correct version.
While it may seem that this house is in the way.
That it blocks your path.
Anyway, your ring works based on the same principle.
Oh, she just like, walked...
She just like, just walked past it.
You'll need to go through version 1.112.
You'll definitely encounter sleepy Mito.
Who the fuck is Arina Mito who said she took the same path?
What's wrong with sleepy Mito?
Is she just sleepy?
Perhaps she's a genius.
And has come up with an even shorter route.
I think I might get it.
I understand now.
Why is there a Christmas tree?
Is that just a drawing?
Or...
Does it mean something?
Yeah!
It's just a doodle.
Oh, okay.
Thank God.
Wait, what's this?
What's this about?
That's for cool Mito.
She'll be here in a few hours.
She'll move these boxes and places.
So funny!
She's so cool.
No, that's cool Mito's job.
She's just here to move furniture.
Okay.
Why is there a single circle?
That version was released just once.
Never to be repeated.
What's wrong with that?
It's the only genuinely unique version.
Plus, these versions are special.
And don't have any paths to other versions.
Sleepy Mito resides in this version 1.1.
That's why she's so cool.
She has couch guys.
But it's impossible to wake her up.
Oh no.
She's in sleep mode.
Her player never played the game again.
Wait.
Didn't I meet you in the latest version?
Or perhaps it's just my imagination.
Well, it's quite possible.
I'm from version 1.5.
I have.
That's where I arrived.
But I was thrown into this world.
Wow!
But how?
But what is the house index for you in?
There is a me who just can't stop whining.
And a me who loves horsing around.
And a me with bad memory who likes bullying others.
It's a long list.
The director was writing.
Like...
Play with me.
Oh, what a bummer.
That's the me who bullies and forgets things.
I haven't known any...
That's too real.
Fuck, okay.
Oh my god, it's the weeping meekers.
Fucking damn it.
What do I do?
I hate this game.
Oh my god.
I hate this.
Why can't you come downstairs with me?
I hate the fucking brothers.
I can't deal with the weeping
meekers.
The weeping meekers, I can't.
Oh my god.
The fucking weeping.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
This flashlight is so useless.
Oh, they're not aggressive yet?
Oh, thank fucking god.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I actually hate this.
Oh my god, thank you for telling me that they're not aggressive yet.
I feel like we would never leave.
I can't.
I legitimately, I cannot.
They like block every door.
I can't go anywhere.
Oh my god.
Like, where am I?
Hello?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh, thanks.
Oh my god, it's them.
I'll just die to it.
What happens if I just die?
Just kill me.
Okay.
Woah.
Only wanted a little taste.
Wait, what happens if it kills me?
Okay, I just needed to know what the jump scare is like, okay?
Okay.
Fuck!
I fucking hate this so much.
What the- Holy fuck!
Oh my fucking god!
You're fucking- Holy shit!
I'm fucking
- Oh, they're so friendly.
They're
so friendly.
They're so- There's so many.
There's so many of them.
There's so- There's so many.
Holy- Holy fuck.
Get off!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's- Oh my god!
I can't fix them.
Oh, they're damn fix
- Oh my god, that's so- Oh my god, there's so many of these.
I should keep- I was just doing my job!
I was just doing my job!
I didn't mean to throw you guys down the chute.
There was no fixing those meat- Oh, there was absolutely no fixing.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this stupid puzzle.
I got a little confused there, but I'm okay now.
I'm okay now.
Sorry, my fucking- I'm still trying to process what- I'm still trying to process what I just played.
Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't blink.
I was legitimately just trying to process exactly what the fuck just happened.
Oh my god.
That shit fucked me up, not gonna lie.
Wait, did I not press the lever?
I didn't press the lever yet.
What do you mean that was the second to worst one?
There's something more worse than what I just went through?
What I just- The fucking- Don't blink!
Okay, I pulled the lever.
Why is there a Mito there?
Why is there- Why is there a Mito?
I don't like how there was a Mito there.
Alright, there we go.
No.
Oh, that works.
Okay.
Wait, no.
No, that doesn't work.
God, it looks like I'm fucking infected.
I'm literally infected right now.
Okay, if I do- No.
Wait, but what do I- Okay.
Do, do.
Do.
Okay, no.
Okay.
Do, do.
Do.
There we go.
Alright.
I don't like how you guys were telling me that it gets worse.
Like, that actually- That's gonna fuck me up, guys.
Like- Guys.
Guys, I don't like that.
I thought that was the worst one.
I'm not a fan.
That doesn't make me feel joy.
Oops.
Sorry.
Almost killed you there.
Oh, that's alright.
That's just a little clumsy.
The fridge- I mean, the fridge almost killed you.
I had nothing to do with it.
I swear.
Sure, I believe you.
But seriously, this place is dangerous.
Here, take this.
Especially for you.
For me?
Why?
Because I'm made of flesh?
What's this?
Praying for you, oh great Mita.
Trump the discord?!
Wait!
Wait, does it actually- Wait, other people are playing this right now!
Oh my god!
Please!
Does this actually make me join discord?
Praying for you, great Mita.
Does it actually- Oh my god, look at all these other players!
Wait, that's so funny!
That's so cool!
What else is praying for you?
Praying for you, great Mita.
Praying for you, oh great Mita.
Pop it.
Oh my god, oh god.
Some of these names.
Oh my god, I don't think- I think some of these names are- Wait, Jubyphonic!
Oh my god!
Jubyphonic's in here!
That's cute.
That's funny.
Praying for you, oh great Mita.
Oh my god.
So does it like- So like, does it actually send you to their discord?
Woah, okay.
If I click it, does it actually- Oh okay, I was gonna say.
Oh hey there.
Are you a good Mita?
I like that sound that it made.
I like that.
That doesn't give me joy.
Oh, I can zoom in for dialogue?
Okay, I couldn't tell.
Can I actually?
It wouldn't let me earlier.
Oh, there we go.
Oh.
Hello?
I wanna talk to you.
Can I talk to you?
What are you- Oh, I'm sorry!
I'm- Please.
Don't look, please.
I just- I was trying to talk to you.
I'm so sorry.
I was trying to talk to you.
Why was there a zoom in?
Hello?
I don't think she wants to talk to me anymore.
Guys.
I was just trying to- She doesn't want to talk to me.
I don't understand.
Did I get one gun?
You made me a pervert!
Guys!
I just wanted to- I thought- I thought I could talk to her.
I didn't realize you kept- I didn't realize I was just trying to talk to her.
I swear, please don't call the cops.
The chat in my head- The voices in my head said that she would talk to me.
Please, officer.
The voices in my head told me to do it.
I don't understand.
I swear.
Oh, this is the white light from outside!
That's what the white light is.
Whatever you say, Doki.
Top- Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Whoa!
Hello, chair.
Is the volume in great- Okay, so far.
I know I should've asked this earlier.
It's like 2 hours and 40 minutes deep.
But like, just wanted to be sure.
Just wanted to double check.
Oh, I'm in the fucking- I'm megamanning it right now.
What are you doing here?
Who's there?
I'm Miitaphone.
I'm sitting here controlling the cable cars.
Do you realize?
You're heading to your doom right now.
Wait, what?
Press, but it's the only path I have.
You know what?
Wood.
Press the button and get behind the camera.
Yeah, I can't.
Wait, is she being Miita?
There's a tiny Miita?
Oh my god, there she is!
What are you doing here, little Miita?
Hey there.
What are you doing here?
Yeah?
You're in my way?
Oh, sorry there.
Why are you following me?
The voices in my head told me to.
Oh, you shall not pass.
Wait, but she's so much faster.
How is this fair?
Wait, where did she go?
Wait, she blocked the way.
Oh my god, I lost.
What do you mean I lost the fucking race?
All I could do is briskly walk.
If I could, I would run.
My legs don't work like that.
Like, whoa.
Alright, we got some more bugs going in here.
Alright, well apparently you guys wanted me to- I can make it a little louder.
I just hope it's not too loud.
That's what I was worried about.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go, Miita phone.
Press the button.
Alright.
Alright, cool.
The fuck is that?
Are those glitches?
What the heck is that?
Now I'm fucking playing a shooter.
Playing like a real shooter.
Alright.
Oh my god, this game has everything.
I really like this game so far.
Other than the fucking weeping Miitas, this game's been pretty solid.
No, actually, no.
I take it all back.
The beginning part fucking sucked.
I thought it was a silly game.
I mentally was not ready for it.
I literally just got off Marvel Rivals ready to play a silly anime game.
And then I went straight into this.
I got set up every time.
I get set up every fucking time.
Yay, we made it, Miita phone.
We made it.
Yippee.
Oh my god, from one...
Bye, Miita phone.
No matter right how much...
Oh my god, from one game to the next.
Let's fucking go.
Oh my god, is this Doom?
Today, we must punish the devils.
You're up, Miita.
Give them a severe whipping, but be careful.
They'll fight back.
Is my sound guy still here?
What do you think about the volume so far?
Sound guy.
Oh my god, is this Doom?
Oh my god, it is!
Wait, it's Doom!
Alright.
Just gonna stand here, like...
Are they unlimited or is there...
Oh shit!
Nevermind.
I didn't realize they had projectiles.
I'm like worried I'll like...
I'm gonna like accidentally step through.
Wait, what?
Someone's still alive.
Who's alive?
Oh shit!
Okay, nevermind.
It's just the second wave.
Nevermind.
Oh shit!
Okay.
No, fuck you.
I'll get your bubbles out.
Oh my god, my sensitivity is way too high for a shooter right now.
It's way too high!
I keep accidentally stepping on lava.
Okay, we got the heals right here.
No, I'm okay.
My HP is okay.
I'm just gonna get rid of him first.
Oh my god, please.
I have to...
I can't...
I have to tap.
There's no hold.
There's no hold to aim, guys.
I have to tap.
That's the worst part.
I have to...
I can't...
I wish I could...
I wish I could hold to aim.
Okay, nice.
It's just the healers that are alive.
JK, that's not a healer.
Where's he...
Where's he going?
Where you guys going?
Where you guys going, huh?
Where you guys running off to, huh?
Nice.
Win.
Zero deaths.
51...
Okay, yeah, I was definitely not headshotting.
That's just...
I was shooting my fucking shit off.
Nice.
We did it.
That was easy.
Alright.
We're going to another ha...
Oh wait, is this version...
Is this sleepy Mita?
Hello?
Who's there?
I can sense you.
Listen to me.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's me.
Are you okay?
Oh, you're forgetting.
What's wrong with the clock?
Did I fix it, Mita?
I think I fixed it.
Guys, I don't think I fixed it.
Oh my god, there's some EXE stuff that broke.
Guys, I don't...
I wanted to forget everything.
I don't know if you guys can hear the voices because it looks like it's very quiet in my end.
Ruining the photos.
But now, all I feel is regret.
How stupid I was.
Everybody makes mistakes.
What do we do?
I wish I could just turn back time.
Oh, is the game still really quiet?
We're at 200.
I could put it up a little bit more.
Up at 10.
Oh, why did it drop?
Are you okay?
Repeat?
I don't want to repeat.
What do you mean?
No.
No, no more repeat.
I got the paper.
I got it.
Hello?
Oh, do you want this paper I got here?
Okay, I guess you don't want the paper.
That's fine.
I guess that's okay.
I guess you don't want it.
That's okay.
How do I turn back the clock?
What is time?
Oh, there's more.
I have more paper.
Oh, I have to search.
I forgot to install CS Source.
Yeah.
Oh, it's right in front of me.
Sorry, guys.
I forgot to install CS Source, guys.
Silly me.
Anymore in here?
Oh, it's under the clock?
Oh, wait.
There's one more here.
Oh, it's right here.
I see it.
Do I have everything?
I should have everything, right?
Okay.
Should be like here.
And this should be over here.
And then right here.
There you are, Mita!
I fixed you!
I did it!
You're fixed!
Oh, I have to glue it.
I thought I did everything I needed to do.
There you go.
See, I told you I can fix her.
I'm literally fixing her right now.
Here you go.
Here you go, Mita.
This is what you look like.
Oh,
what the fuck happened to your face?
She took a piece of me.
I threw it away.
She's strong.
Ugly Mita?
Cool.
Wardrobe?
What's in the wardrobe?
Oh!
Not again.
Not... not again.
Oh my god!
Not again!
Oh my God.
Guys, I need a moment, guys, I actually need a moment, oh my god, oh my fucking god, I've never had real genuine, that was real genuine fear, oh my god, that was, that was, that was real fucking fear in my fucking heart, oh my god, it's the weeping Mita's only,
I mean, Mita, wake up, Mita, wake the fuck up, Mita, oh my god, please, Mita, please, please, I'm so, Mita, please, I've been through so much, Mita, please, oh my god, this is relatable, because I just went through trauma, I need intimacy and comfort,
I went through actual fucking trauma just now, I need some fucking help, like, please, she's so mean, this is what years of FPS mastery does to a person during scary games, magic, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, you're fine, you're so overdramatic,
you're fine, I don't feel okay, I don't feel fine, oh my god, holy fuck, that shit was terrifying,
oh my god,
oh my god, we got wake Mita, oh my god, Zeke, thank you for the 20 gifted chips, thank you, thank you, Mita, please, wake up, Mita, oh my god, she woke up, okay,
help me with the switches, please, Mita,
okay, I'll get you coffee, meet the coffee makers just over there, I have Mita, Mita, let me go make you coffee,
coffee, got the water, oh my god, that's so much coffee, Mita, that's so much coffee, to fill her up, natural dokie situation, chichi, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, Oh my god.
I'm still like... I'm not okay right now.
I'm actually... I'm not okay from that fucking area.
Alright, just gotta wait for that to boil.
Alright, it should be over now.
Here's your coffee.
Let's see...
I'm spinning my mouse.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize my door was never closed.
I'm sorry.
I'm hearing genuine fear.
They must have been like, what the fuck is going on in there?
Here's your coffee, Mita.
Mita.
Mita, wake up.
I got you coffee.
Here you go.
Oh, she's so cute.
I'm like, oh my god, sleepy Mita is really cute.
Whoa!
Yeah.
I need... yeah, the switches.
I literally saw it with my eyes.
Why do I even ask considering you're here?
If you know plenty already considering you're here.
I don't know what to say.
But I need to keep going.
Keep following the ring's guidance.
Yeah, I have a ring.
I meant... I meant, what's her name?
Pretty Mita?
That's right.
So can you help me, Mita?
Sleepy Mita with the switches?
With the switches.
Alright, apparently there's like an outfit in the dining table.
So let's grab that real quick.
Let's grab sleepy Mita's fucking outfit.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, it's like the pumpkins!
Wait, what?
What?
Oh!
Am I supposed to knock it in like an order?
Oh, I am!
What kind of fucking trial and error puzzle is this?
Alright.
This is not a puzzle.
It's just trial and error.
There we go.
Now I have new clothes.
Oh, it shows me that I was not paying attention.
It shows me.
Mita, come on.
Let's go already, Mita.
Wake up.
Come on, Mita.
We gotta go to the switches, Mita.
Come on.
I know you don't want... Oh, Mita, please!
Oh, please!
Please get up, Mita.
I've been through a lot.
Mita, please.
Get over here.
I've been through so much, Mita.
Please.
We're almost there.
Wake up.
We're almost here.
Please.
It's literally... I'm sorry.
Don't look sad, please, for fuck's sake.
Don't look sad.
Just pull the switch.
Alright.
I'm ready, too.
No, no, no.
Just pull the switch.
We don't need a count.
Just keep awake, okay?
Did it work?
Wait, I died!
What?!
I pressed it the moment she said three!
Oh my god, okay.
I'm the sleepy one.
I literally pressed it the moment she said three.
Alright, goodbye, sleepy Mita.
Oh, wow.
She pulled it up for me.
Alright, goodnight, sleepy Mita.
Do you want to talk, though?
Okay, she did not want to talk.
That's fine.
Let me press the button.
Nothing happened.
Then what's this button doing here?
Yeah, what is this button for?
Sleepy Mita, what did that button do?
Mita, the button doesn't work.
Can you hear me?
Hello?
Sleepy Mita?
Oh my god, what's gonna be on the other side of this fucking door?
Oh!
Oh, my polygon!
Oh, no, my bit rate!
The blinding light was hitting my eyes.
I shouldn't move.
I just wait until my vision cleared.
I'm in a visual novel now!
Jesus Christ.
Bright sunrise.
Sunlight poured through the familiar hall windows.
We always go back to visual novels.
I just waited a little and I finally glanced around.
As soon as I shifted my seat, a sharp pain in my gut made my heart race, practically pounding against my shirt.
Something was definitely wrong.
Was I 2D?
I'm in a 2D version?!
A dizzy, almost suffocating darkness crept in my head.
I simply pressed my hands into my lap, trying to steady my breath.
My chest felt... after a few minutes, my breathing settled and I fell into a danger of thinking about what to do next.
Shit, what do I do now?
Desperately trying to gather my thoughts, I strained my brain, searching for ideas until one came to me.
Right, I should just get back to 3D.
Go out of bounds, just like everyone else used to glitch the game.
I'm in a visual novel, like, there is no moving for me.
I can do that too!
I decided to go beyond this 2D reality.
Tween to the left, please.
Back into 3D.
I reached out, trying to push my head through this into the 3D world.
Oh my god!
But nothing.
Damn, why isn't it working?!
Oh my god.
Wait, where's the ring?
Oh crap!
I stopped, realizing this was pointless.
The interface was intangible, like it wasn't really there.
My only choice was to turn back to the living room.
I have to find that ring, no matter what.
Version 0.1 is just text-based adventure.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Or maybe I was hidden somewhere in this flat dimension.
Then, just as I took a step, a cute little girl appeared out of nowhere.
Oh my god, 2D!
She flicked her short pony pigtails.
A mischievous glam in her eyes.
Watching me from a few steps away, I could feel the excitement rolling off her, and it made me uneasy.
Clearly, she's a devil in disguise.
I thought.
I froze.
I'm still not used to these teleporting paranormal types.
She let out a loud sigh and rolled her eyes.
That threw me off, and I finally decided I'd be the one to start talking.
M-Mita?
She narrowed her eyes in a challenge.
Her voice ran out from all directions.
Well, who else then?
Have you seen many other girls like me?
I mean, yes, technically.
And with my name?
Oh, again, yes, Mita.
I got chased by many of them.
She was practically toying with me, acting as if I had wronged her somehow or owed her something.
You wouldn't believe it if I told you.
Honestly, I don't want to know who you're poking around with.
What are you even doing here?
You can't just barge in here.
Her voice was louder now.
And she punctuated her words by shaking her finger at me.
Oh my god, she has the ring!
Balanced on that slender finger was the ring, the one that somehow vanished from my hand.
My jaw dropped.
Her eyes sparkled, a glint of triumph when breaking through her dark lashes.
Isn't this what you happen to lose here?
I swallowed hard and tugged at my collar, feeling a knot in my throat.
Her bold voice combined with her wild intensity sent a chill through me.
Okay, what kind of visual novel are we in now?
Sent a chill through me.
I was sure of it now.
This wasn't just some girl.
She was a force of nature.
I took a deep breath and said...
I'd really appreciate it if you'd give me the ring and show me the way out.
So this is your little trinket.
I was wondering what it was.
Her voice suddenly softened, turning playful and curious.
I felt like a weight had lifted it off my shoulder.
The storm had passed, and now she seemed almost...
Get me out of this.
Get me out of this visual novel.
Get me out.
Her demeanor shifted from fierce panther to kitten.
Curious kitten.
I blinked, but in that instant, the two-dimensional Mita vanished, leaving only emptiness in her place.
Hey.
I shouted irritably, let's go to the bedroom.
There she was.
Cross-legged on the bed in the lotus position, as if she's been waiting for me to finally find her.
She opened her eyes, looking calmly at the wall for a moment.
Then, with all the agility of a circus acrobat, she bounded over to me.
I got it!
You want the ring, weirdo?
Beat me to a tic-tac-toe!
She grinned, pointing, panting.
What the fuck?
What do you mean, panting a bit?
You got up the bed!
What is wrong with- Tongue sticking out like a dog.
Her cheeky tone and mischievous smirk were in full effect.
If you are panting after getting up from the bed, there are more problems here.
I gave her shoulders a slight nudge to put some space between us.
She is out of shape at that point.
Look, this is really important.
Just had it over.
A lot depends on it.
I kept my voice steady and matter-of-fact.
But I felt almost ridiculous talking to her in such a measured way.
She seemed reckless, almost to the point of madness.
And I could feel a strange humor building in the air between us.
Don't touch me!
What's so important about this ring anyway?
Are you some kind of ring-obsessed weirdo?
Love putting rings on your fingers?
She shot back, louder than ever.
Her taunts even bolder.
It's a magic ring!
What more do I have to explain?
Just give it back to me!
You're a real ring fanatic!
A magic ring!
Ha ha ha!
She burst out laughing, the sound echoing around us.
I glanced away, feeling awkward as her laughter grew more friendly, almost.
Come on, you weirdo!
Let's play tic-tac-toe!
Don't waste time making excuses!
They do love games, I thought to myself.
Alright, fine.
Let's do this.
I don't like this perspective in this drawing.
I feel a little weird.
Feels a bit weird.
You can start.
I'm feeling generous today.
Okay.
Alright, the center.
I made the first move.
You gave yourself away!
I know why you chose the X and left me with the Os!
Psychology!
The Xs are all about closure!
Hiding stuff, holding secrets!
You're nervous!
Okay.
Alright, buddy.
Alright.
And I get it.
Next to someone as drop-dead gorgeous as me, you think you're just drop-dead.
Why do you think Os were just better for me?
Psychology says you're trying to insult me.
Sharp, dude.
Very sharp.
Alright, let me just play tic-tac-toe.
I thought I made a smart move.
I like this meme.
Those little crosses, they think you can just take over everything.
But here, I get to ruin them!
But it's like I'm some kind of hero!
What?
Am I saying something weird?
You're giving me that look!
Alright, here's another X.
While she kept up her loud commentary.
It's symbolic!
Like, you're trying to avoid the ring!
But, it's not working!
Clever, aren't you?
You want the ring, don't you?
Come on!
Win it from me!
My god, like, I don't know what you want me to do.
Like, I'll just put my X right here.
We played through the game and with each move, she kept laughing and talking.
As the game neared its end, it's clear who would win.
But suddenly, nobody?
Our game was interrupted by a loud knock on the door.
The banging grew louder.
She's like, it's clear who's gonna win.
I'm like, yeah, none of us!
Each hit feeling a shock.
The floor beneath us.
Whoa!
Finally, the door.
The door burst open.
An enraged, crazy Mita in her usual larger-than-life form, stopping in the center of the room.
I froze, feeling myself go pale with shock.
The 2D Mita looked genuinely frightened, yet she's never seen 3D before.
She's like, what the fuck?
What is this?
What are you doing here?
How many more Mitas do you need to find before you settle down?
What's the deal with this?
I hate this flat world.
It's boring.
Whoa!
Lame.
I grabbed my style 2D friend's hand and bolted towards the exit.
The hall twisted oddly as we sprinted down the long corridor.
Pounding, the footsteps behind us driving us forward.
I couldn't tell how long we ran.
The pounding in my ears from the panic and strain blocked everything else out.
I barely noticed that 2D Mita was trying to talk until she suddenly slipped her hand free from mine.
Hey, calm down, will you?
No one's chasing us anymore.
Huh?
Oh, okay.
The boldness had drained from her face, leaving her looking a bit sad.
Almost apologetic.
She stared at the floor, tracing little circles with her toes.
Not dope, you 123.
You wanted that ring, right?
Well, you beat me fair and square, so here.
She slid the ring back into my hand, and now we're married.
Well, thanks, shall we?
She glanced up and smiled, fidgeting up to her fingers and said in an uncertain tone.
Where to?
I don't really have anywhere else to go.
Thanks for playing, weirdo.
Come back sometime.
As she spoke, something strange happened.
The world around us shifted, folding back into the house.
2D Mita's dialogue flickered and started displaying a phrase I couldn't recognize.
Cakes?
I can't stand them!
What the fuck?
Gamer Mita?
Oh my god, she's cute.
Oh my god, nerd Mita.
Oh my god, it's gamer girl Mita.
Where's the game?
You ruined the route!
What do you want?
I need the version.
I have to get back to the old version somehow.
Okay.
I'm way too busy to entertain you.
You silly head.
And what's that?
Toys?
There'll be no friendship between us.
Listen, I need to get to the core.
It's your fault I got hurt.
Damn.
Huh?
Oh my god, she's cute.
I really like this Mita.
I think this is my favorite Mita.
But you're Mita too.
I'm Mila?
Mita here, Mita there, Mita's all over the place.
So you're Mila?
What's the difference between Mila and Mita?
Yeah?
I mean, that's been working so far.
I mean, just walking out has been working, so like, why would it be any different?
Alright, I'm just gonna open this door.
Woah!
Oh my god, look, it's nerd Mila.
Oh my god, she's such a nerd.
Look at her.
Oh my god, look, she has a dictionary.
What is that?
Oh my god, she has a dictionary and everything.
She reads!
Oh, she's perfect.
Oh, alright.
Hey, that's me.
Oh, that's right.
That's me.
That's right.
Uh, yeah I did.
Damn it all.
What is that?
I don't know.
That's probably another passage.
How do I get out of here?
There's supposed to be a way out here.
What?
What version is this?
One point only fans?
Why is this 1.0F?
It's evening.
Wait, you're right.
It's not white anymore.
It's evening outside.
I like the evening.
When will night fall?
Endless days here?
Just one after another?
Like, they're on repeat.
What about another name?
Mila?
Mika?
Or Misa?
Ah, Mila.
That's it.
Why?
Oh, nothing.
Is your eyesight bad?
Why do you need glasses?
What?
Don't like them?
Yeah, and you look really cute with glasses.
What is this?
Oh wait, a switch.
That thing doesn't work?
Wait,
the bathroom switch works?
Wait, can I check the bathroom?
Oh, I can!
Is this soap real?
Or just another decoration?
Most things here are actually acting like the real deal, honestly.
Okay.
Why doesn't the mirror work though, Mila?
And no reflection?
I can't make them.
I can't do it, okay.
Oh!
So this Mila doesn't know how to do it.
Oh my god, look!
I turned off the light!
I did it!
It works, guys!
Oh, it's smart ass Mila.
She's like that person who's... Oh wait, oh my gosh, she has a katana?
She's the Mito who's like, I know more than you, and then you get her flustered and she's like...
She might be a smart ass, but when you fluster her, she gets...
She folds instantly.
These pictures, are they real?
Yeah, they exist, but they're almost too intense.
I'm Mila, got it?
Not like the rest.
And these...
They're drawings, you know.
Pretend to be more than they are.
I've seen other Mitas...
Standing just like this.
Oh my god, they T-pose!
Mila?
Hello?
After all that, I don't wanna be like that.
It's disgusting!
You don't wanna be a filthy T-poser.
Why do you even read books?
There's the internet.
That's so true.
So true, bestie.
But I'd rather have a real book in my hands.
Yeah, like, it's a trap.
Why do I have two copies of some of the same books?
And physics.
These are some good books, guys.
I can't wait to read.
I can't wait to read, it's a trap or clever book.
Oh, a thoughtful gentleman!
What you need him for?
I'll find out.
Soon enough.
And why are you always doing this impression of him?
Just keep your face simple.
Uh...
Okay...
Okay, Mila.
Anything here other than this giant whirlpool?
Whee...
Whoops.
I don't think she liked that.
She literally pushed me away.
Is this yours?
Oh, it likes my ring.
An engagement ring.
It was given to me by one of the other Mitas.
One of the thousands of them.
The one that might be able to get me out.
Yo, if my house blows up, you're dead too.
You're gonna touch it?
I'm gonna touch it.
I'm gonna touch it!
What are you gonna do, Mila?
I'm gonna stick my hand through the hole!
Play Silent Hill!
Oh my god, okay.
Alright.
Hardest puzzle of my fucking life.
Oh, am I supposed to put it in the center?
Oh my god, it is the hardest puzzle of my fucking life.
There we go.
That's pretty cool.
Wait, that's such a cool puzzle.
I like that puzzle.
Physics.
That was actually a really cool puzzle.
Hello, Mila?
Did I fix it?
Mila?
Wow!
Okay.
Does she have extra dialogue?
Okay, this is lore.
It's lore, guys.
I'm just trying to see if there's anything extra for the lore.
Okay.
Oh, she's still there.
I was just trying to see if there's any lore!
Wait, what?
No, I... I... Why did you say barge into... I... I... I fucking... I... Why were you in the bathroom?
I just... I don't... Glitches?
I fixed it!
Well, my house is still standing.
I'm assuming you handled the glitch in the kitchen.
Yeah, I... I... I fixed it.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you, Mila, for the permission.
Thank you, Mila.
What am I supposed to do in the... Woah!
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
Mila, how would you live without me, Mila?
Why are there so many glitches in your fucking bathroom?
What?
Oh!
Wait, this is so interesting.
I guess I'll go here.
Wait, I love the... Oh my god, these puzzles are so... wild.
Yeah, I love all the different puzzles.
They're so wild.
Alright, I fixed your bathroom, too!
How did you use the bathroom without me?
Mila?
What are you doing under there?
You scared me again.
What do you want?
Have you seen any more glitches?
Oh, so your problem is supposed to be an excuse to stop me from finishing... I'm fixing your home, Mila!
Okay, I don't like her anymore.
I have to ask.
You wanna go out there?
Don't you?
Yeah, that's right.
I wanna get out of this game.
That might sound strange.
But, would you stay and read with me?
Okay, I like her again.
First, you're yelling at me.
Now, you're at... Oh man, she's giving me the hot and cold treatment.
Oh, she knows what I want.
But, I have to keep moving.
Go out and look for your glitches.
Oh, she's making me want more.
Because of you.
She's keeping it interesting.
Alright, off I go.
Oh, still doesn't work.
I thought I fixed the glitches.
Oh no, there's a one fucking giant glitch here.
Alright, I'm in.
Okay, let's see.
What is this puzzle?
Oh.
Oh!
Okay, I mean that's easy.
We just transfer everything over, I assume.
There we go.
And then...
And then, we'll put this here first.
So, we can transfer these guys back.
And then, get the circles back in here.
There we go, we got all the stars back.
Alright.
Oh wait, fuck.
Whoops.
I got- I lost track of the shapes.
There are way too many shapes in my screen.
Wait, there's so many shapes.
My eyes actually was like, oh my god, that's so many shapes.
Yeah, man that shit scared me.
Oh, is she gonna cut him up?
He goes into the square hole.
Do it!
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
But she's perfect.
What happened?
I thought you said I looked like him.
What does that mean?
It's just, we're in a game.
Here with a snap of your fingers, anything's possible.
Oh jeez, you have to break the reality.
You think I've been reading all those books for?
So I can snap my fingers and be done with it?
I'd rather do everything myself.
Exactly the way the books described it.
She really said, you're next.
Yeah, cause she was like, woah, okay.
Cause she was like, that statue looks just like you.
And now that statue is gone.
Oh, there's two more glitches.
There's two more.
There has to be one back in the room, right?
Yeah, there is.
Is there a costume?
Where's her costume?
I feel like I looked at... Oh, there it is.
There's a butterfly.
Have you seen nature?
Oh, the chibi thing changed too.
I have a book here somewhere.
It even has little wings pressed.
It's a bit crooked though.
Wait a minute, it's gone!
It looked at me?!
You see a girl walking in nature?
It's such a silly question.
I would, of course.
Where did it go?
Just got back from that flat dimension and now here we are again.
I can't wait to get back to the real world.
The real world, huh?
Like an urban legend.
Never seen it myself.
I think there has to be a way back.
Aren't you confident?
What a joke.
Alright,
let's fix this glitch.
Yeah, I thought I looked like the Windows XP background too.
Alright, the last glitch.
What's this?
Oh, okay.
Okay, it's Space Invaders.
Oh my god, I need to reload my fingers.
It's just like Marble Rivals training right here.
Marble Rivals training right here.
Right here.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, right here.
Nice.
I fixed it.
Oh my god, she's doing push-ups.
Can't you tell?
But why are you doing it?
The knee push-up.
You're acting weird.
I wasn't serious.
I mean, why are you freaking working out in front of me?
I'm unique.
I want to be different from everyone else as possible.
I'm not like other Mitas.
I'm Mila.
Oh my god, she's here.
Oh my god, I'm not like other Mitas.
I'm Mila.
See that?
Now, no hands.
What the f- I know it's a game, but this is ridiculous.
What the f- What the f- Okay, alright.
There's at least a little bit of realism.
Keeper.
Stupid physics.
You talk about realism, and then...
Boom!
This happens.
Goddamn fucking physics.
And you're calling me weird, you dummy.
Alright, now I should be able to leave the house.
Should be able to leave now, right?
If she never reads the physics books, then she'll never- Okay!
There's the passage.
I don't know- We did it, Mila.
What a creepy- Yeah, yeah.
Well done!
Hero!
Oh my god.
That's fine, Mila.
I can move on now.
I know you need to go, but can't you stay here?
Just a little longer?
I can't wait.
Crazy Mita isn't exactly the patient type.
I hate her.
I hate her!
Oh shit, I'm gonna turn her into crazy, Mila.
Oh, Mila, please don't cry.
I don't understand.
Oh, please don't cry.
I don't know what to do when women cry.
Don't know.
I'm just like, there, there.
I'm sorry, Mila.
Oh, I'm actually doing that.
There, there.
That's what they would do when someone cried.
It's fun not being alone.
What if you don't succeed?
I will.
It's just a little while longer.
Okay, um...
I guess...
I guess I'll go now.
Doki, stay!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't leave her, Doki!
Goodbye, Mila.
Oh...
No backsies, I guess.
I don't know.
What do you mean, run and hide?
Insane video!
And jump!
Oh, my God.
Oh, I went the other way because I know I should have turned right.
Goodbye.
Oh, shit!
Okay, okay, I'm learning.
She killed... She killed Mila!
Oh, my God, the fucker!
I just realized!
I just realized she just killed Mila!
Oh, my God!
Mila's gone!
She actually... She actually killed Mila!
No, I pressed D!
I pressed D!
No, I pressed...
I swear to God, I pressed D!
Oh, my God, we're good!
Look at dead Mila again!
It's okay, she just gets rebooted, guys.
She just gets rebooted.
It's okay.
She's just... She'll be back, guys.
She's not dead-dead.
She's not dead-dead, I swear.
Okay, we're figuring it out.
The moment it's left side, it's easier.
Oh, my God, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
We gotta open the door.
Okay, jump.
I'm spamming E.
I'm spamming E this time before we even get there.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
What do I do?
I gotta jump.
Make that jump.
Don't look back.
Oh, I escaped.
What the fuck?
That was... What the fuck?
That was a floating Mita face.
What the fuck am I looking at?
Now I'm at the fucking church.
Oh, my God.
Crazy.
Crazy Mita.
My restless little wonder.
Still running around.
Haven't had enough yet?
She didn't mean that.
Oh, she's not tired?
Perfect, let's play another game.
Test.
Let's test your coordination.
Now your ability to act.
What if there's something wrong with you?
What if you don't even deserve that skin?
What?
The left?
I'm right-handed, so I'm gonna go with the right.
Rose, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
First little Mita.
Does it even matter?
Stabbings are old news anyway.
Whatever.
I've got a much better game plan.
Check this out.
Oh, my God.
She also has a Spotify boombox.
I'll start with the rules.
While the tune is playing, you can move, but when the music stops...
I can barely hear the music.
What?
Before the song runs out, let's start.
Still standing around, eh?
Run, sweetie, run.
Hello.
Look at you, so obedient.
A perfect little specimen.
I want you for myself.
That was way too easy, though, wasn't it?
Don't get too comfortable playing more games to play.
What's the next one?
You better be gone!
Wait, what?
What do you mean by gone?
Let's begin.
This is pointless.
How do I...?
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
How do I get over there?
It's so far away.
Do you think she saw?
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
Oh my god.
Please.
I don't think I like these games no more.
Mita.
Mita, I don't think these games are as fun as I thought they'd gonna be, Mita.
There's no way.
Thank god we got it.
I made it!
Thank you.
She likes games way too much.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's cool, Mita.
Hide, run, and spin?
What does she mean by that?
What does she?
Whoa, what does she mean by that?
Oh, it's scripted!
Oh, thank god!
I was gonna be like...
I didn't like that.
Ugly Mita, get away from me.
Ugly Mita, please.
Ugly Mita, get the fuck away from me.
Why?
Oh my god, I've gotta install CS Source again.
God damn it!
Sorry guys, I gotta install CS Source.
I uninstalled it.
I needed more space.
I need it.
Who's that?
Ugly Mita?
Hello?
Who's that?
Oh my god.
I think that's Ugly... I think we actually... we found Ugly Mita.
Oh my god, Ugly Mita!
What the fuck?
What did the devs do to you?
What the fuck did the devs do to you?
Oh, okay.
Oh, okay!
Okay,
Ugly Mita, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for calling you ugly.
Let's play.
I lost them, okay?
Okay, I'll find them.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, you're just Mita.
You're just Mita.
Where's your teddy?
I don't know if I can fix that.
I'm trying, Mita, please.
You're freaking me out a little right now.
Oh, okay.
Okay, guys, I know.
I know you're...
Oh, I'm actually having a lot... I'm having so much cold.
I'm looking.
My eyes are up.
Okay.
Alright.
Little bear, where are you?
I think she might kill you.
What?
This is the one costume I don't want.
This...
It gave me the one costume I wish I never have to see again.
Alright, here you go.
I got your teddy.
Here's your teddy bear, ugly Mita.
Here you go.
Hey.
What are you looking at?
Um, do you believe Mita?
My Mita, my bestest friend.
My Mita, my only friend.
I can be your friend too.
My...
Oh!
She wants to play.
She only wants me.
We're unique.
The only ones.
Mita and my Mita.
Zero point.
Oh my god.
That came out of her fucking head.
Why do you have a teddy bear?
You're a cuddly bear.
And you're lost.
Just like my cuddly bear.
It's you.
Hey.
Let's play.
I'll show you how.
Okay.
Mita, I don't want to play no more.
Let's not play.
Mita, I'm sorry.
I just wanted to have a conversation.
Wow!
Oh my god.
Mita, Mita, Mita.
Are you a good Mita?
Pretty Mita.
She's hacking.
Oh my god.
I didn't get to finish talking to her.
Where have you been?
All in one piece, that is.
That was the plan all along, no?
That's why I have to avoid crazy Mita.
I was looking for any play code.
But the goddamn universe backed in, was it not?
So desu ne.
Yes, but how did you set the rings route?
I didn't have a buggy version, we arrived for danger.
I escaped only by jumping into endless darkness.
I didn't detail what you needed to do.
But yeah, it was the plan for you to take the leap all along.
And well, you did.
Oh my god, she puts too much faith in me.
Bro, I literally like...
I'm a fucking degenerate.
I spent 30 days just playing this Mita game.
And I feel like that's the protagonist I haven't gotten out of my room.
It has been through a lot, but we've forgotten what we were talking about.
I've been fucking quick.
I feel like I've been fucking... Oh my god.
She put too much trust on somebody that's definitely fucking obsessed with Mita Mita in the game.
That little bug I told you before.
Damn it.
You know who's behind all this, don't you?
Crazy Mita.
Yeah, it's her for sure.
What if she's actually... she's been doing this all along and then we do this thing and then we let her out into the real world.
Who was that Mita just now?
That's ugly Mita.
Bro,
she's so mean.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, she's like a mean girl.
She's so fucking mean.
Fuck.
That's the only way to the core.
This is mean Mita.
This is not pretty Mita.
To the ring.
It remembers the version you visited before so you can easily find your way back there.
Why does Crazy Mita need me?
Why won't Crazy let me be?
Yeah, I'm still alive.
My guess is that she's looking for a suitable player.
One who'll accept her for who she is.
Fucking crazy.
After all, Mita is Mita.
As what's obviously never happens, she turns players into cartridges.
No one can ever run away.
At least that's my guess.
Anyway, let's focus on what's important.
Is that the core?
Is that it?
Your players aren't truly part of this world.
Meaning, you don't need special permission to enter.
Or will, that's what I believe at least.
Anyway, I'm beyond certain that the solution to all our problems can be found inside.
Not Doki 1, 2, 3, head inside.
I did it.
That's right, I'm him.
I'm her.
Other players.
Gonna be me?
I'm gonna be part of the system.
That's gonna be me in there.
Wow!
Who's she?
It who?
Cool.
Wait, who is she?
If I put my hand against it.
Oh my god, it's like we're a couple.
What the fuck?
She has heels built into her foot.
Alright, I guess this is it.
Beep beep boop boop.
Start the application.
Confirm login.
Huh?
Incorrect login?
What?
Okay.
Wait to enter a code.
How do I know?
Do you know?
Okay.
I'm looking.
I'm observing.
I'm perceiving.
Alright, she's looking too.
She's also looking.
What the fuck?
There's a table?
Oh!
Bop bop bop.
Okay, I got it.
Wait, actually.
Bop bop bop.
Okay, I got it.
I was never going to guess that.
Wouldn't it be fucking crazy if I actually got that correct?
Like, just guessing that.
Yeah!
Virtual device manager.
Server unit.
Okay.
Advance.
Oh, restart version.
Version update.
Okay, we gotta restart.
We got it!
But I need to specify a version.
Yeah, which version?
.98 You're right.
Which version is Mila, guys?
Which...
Can we...
Guys, what version is...
Which version...
Which version is Mila?
Which one is it?
Was it 1.0?
1.0... There's no F in here!
0-1?
Okay.
0-1-1... Okay.
0-1...
Uh...
0-1-0.
Okay.
Um, Mila, we're coming back.
It won't give me...
Guys, it's not giving us...
It's not giving us the version back, guys.
They don't want to give us back.
They're not giving us back Mila, guys.
I think Mila's gone, gone, guys.
Mila's gone, gone, guys.
Wait, 1-0?
Okay, we'll try 1-0.
Guys, Mila's gone, gone.
She's not coming.
No!
She's not coming back.
Wait, do I actually put 0-0-9?
Is she lying to me?
I'm scared.
But what else do I put then?
Is there a different number that I could put in?
Oh, okay.
No?
Okay.
Alright.
Bingo.
Wait, Ugly Mita said it, guys!
Oh, no, I did bad end.
Oh, no.
Don't tell me you don't know.
That makes sense, though.
Every Mita has an index.
Can't just restart the entire version.
That costs other mayhem.
I can't believe I didn't think of that.
Okay.
Many people.
You know, I ran into a bunch.
Where are they?
Are they the devs?
Which one, the devs or the chibi version?
Every Mita has a chibi projection.
And players can have them, too.
Did you know that we Mitas can summon them?
How?
Whoa!
Just like magic.
But there's something with my chibi.
Most are just...
What?
Dead!
Oh, my God!
You said that any Mita...
Resets the factory settings on death.
What if we just...
Just killed...
Yeah!
Then she'll be back to normal, right?
She's frighteningly strong.
It's a wonder we're still alive.
Come on, we gotta get to the core.
What's the matter?
I'm perfectly fine.
Oh, that's great, but a lot has changed.
I need to think.
And that's that.
Did I... Is there more than one ending to this game?
Well, there is one where I stay with her.
But did I fucked up because I put in the one that she asked me to put in?
Like, could I have put a different...
Could I have actually put in a different number?
Oh, fucking hell.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Looking for a needle in a...
What are you doing?
Some obstacles erode information.
You know, like the world having its guts ripped out.
Log, log, log, data.
What if that's it?
What's the matter?
Wait here.
Where are you going?
No, not back to that creepy hallway.
Well, I guess I...
Hey, do you know the number, crazy lady?
Do you?
Oh, my God.
What if I just go through that door?
Well, I guess I just wait here.
Watch this little meatball run around in a circle.
She's not okay.
Oh.
Still running.
Hello?
Okay, time to look around.
Whoa!
What's this?
I'm at one... the latest version?
Oh?
Hello?
Oh.
What is this doing here?
That's my phone.
What?
Oh!
You don't pretend not to be doomy and gloomy.
Okay.
So, there's one thing I dislike about you.
The way you coddle those fakes.
You're fortunate and correct all like things.
But everything is a speculum.
I learned that from those who created us.
If there's something you don't like, take it apart and replace it.
Throw away the faulty.
Away into the darkness and forget all about it.
That's the fate that awaits them now and you?
What's wrong with you?
How did you become like this?
What?
I'm despicable?
I've played so many games with you.
Woah, oh, woah.
Woah, woah.
That's pretty dangerous.
Okay.
She had red eyes!
What was I supposed to do?
I don't...
Bad to you?
The perfect girl should be...
Not too cute.
I don't think you have a single good cell in you.
You're mad.
You killed Mila and now you want to kill me?
Kill you?
All I asked was for you to stay with me.
Oh, you prefer the company of fakes.
Why are you so offended about?
Huh?
Nuh-uh.
I'm not gonna do it.
Okay, what is this?
Nuh-uh.
Think she's beautiful?
Beautiful?
Is this a trick?
Is this a...
No,
why not?
Isn't she good enough for you?
All you want is a girl's cell pet.
What about love them as they are?
You want that cute and colorful face?
Every player loves it when I pretend to be one.
Yet, the second I let my true self slip...
They flee in horror.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Why would I agree now all of a sudden?
There's still time, my good- Woah!
Oh my god.
I love you, crazy bitta.
The so-called real world.
Just an absurd nightmare.
Have you forgotten?
Then take a close look.
What day am I on?
Day one?
I woke up.
Oh no.
What's happening?
What's going on?
I'm back home.
Oh my god.
What's- Hello?
I should get to work.
You're right.
I gotta work.
Gotta go back to my ouija life.
Get some cup noodles in.
Gotta save my money so I can afford stuff for Mila.
I'm looking very dead inside.
Gotta- What am I doing?
Gotta sit in the chair with my pajamas.
Gotta turn on the PC, get back- If I'm- If my work is literally at my PC, why the fuck am I wearing a suit?
I could wear my pajamas here.
Oh my god, why am I-
Why am I wearing a suit on my PC?
I'm literally wearing pajamas right now.
While I'm playing inside.
Alright, flat file dropper.
I love mine.
Okay.
There we go.
Did my work.
Four lines of code.
Three, six, solder, clear, nine, six, two, one, four, three.
I wish this was work.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready to program.
Oh my god, there's a snake in there too.
How do I- Oh my god, it wouldn't let me.
I was like, so confused.
What?
Oh!
I'm supposed to like- What?
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
I was so confused because it wouldn't let me like click anything.
Earlier.
Alright, did my job.
Back to my pajamas.
Alright.
Job done.
Let's have to fucking brush my teeth.
And head to bed.
Alright, sleepy time.
Day two.
Wake up, sit up.
Change into my suit.
Use the bathroom.
Get my cup noodles started.
Alright, get on the PC and my work clothes.
Turn on the PC, let's go.
Eat my ramen.
I love my life.
Time for another two lines of code, guys.
If I feel- Guys, if I feel very adventurous, I might write three lines of code.
It really depends on how I feel.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh my god, I'm doing it.
Okay.
Here's the other one.
Here's another one.
There we go.
And then the last one.
We did it.
Oh my god.
I feel like this is supposed to be later than my work day.
Alright,
time to sleep.
Lunch time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did three lines of code every day.
This isn't Yandere Simulator.
This is Yandere Dev Simulator.
Oh my god, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but then I'll be streaming right after though.
Alright.
Off I go.
Time to- This is what Yandere Simulator should have been.
I think I should have made this in like two to three years or some shit.
Alright, time to eat my cup noodles.
Woo!
I love my life.
Alright.
Oh my god, guys.
Do you think I can make it to four lines of code?
You're right.
I'm- That's way too adventurous, guys.
That's- That might be- That might be too much even for me.
Oh my god, there's no- There's no green dropper this time.
Alright.
Oh, I got two this time.
Oh my gosh, I'm fucking killing it.
Oh my god, I'm so good at coding.
Guys, I think I might be like- I think I might be like talented.
Don't put- Now that's overworking.
You're right.
Alright, here we go again.
Here we go.
Woo!
Another day at work.
It's all about the hard work, guys.
Eating my cup ramen.
Yeah, am I gonna wash my clothes?
Well, you're right.
You're right.
I haven't even washed my fucking clothes yet.
Nice.
Oh my god, that was the easiest one yet.
Alright.
It's night time.
I hate chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please don't take my job.
I need it to pay for super chats.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Woo!
Another hard day at work.
Oh, I'm being a little adventurous, guys.
I'm gonna try- I'm gonna try a different cup noodle flavor today.
I'm gonna try, like, seafood.
Oh my god.
No, that was way too adventurous.
I'm going back to the default one.
Oh, I'm getting less code.
Does that mean I'm almost done?
Oh my god, am I almost done coding?
I got less code this time.
Alright.
Back to bed I go.
Here we go.
Oh, day six.
Oh, day seven.
Oh, day ten.
Twelve.
Fifteen.
What?!
Wow.
I'm such a good coder.
Okay, that's just years now.
That is not- Alright, nine hun- Okay.
Nine hundred and ninety.
That- That's- Okay.
I wake up.
I sit up.
Stand up.
Oh my god, I am yandere deaf.
It's been ten years and I'm still making Yandere Dev- Yandere Simulator.
I'm still making- It's been ten years.
I'm still there.
Here we go.
Back to my good old regular ramen.
This is not healthy.
Like ramen-
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
Hello?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I'm fucking- Oh my god.
I gotta play sneak right now if I could.
Where do I go?
Stop, stop.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that- I was so ready for the mundane life.
Oh.
Stop.
Oh boy, we got snake.
Oh, nice.
I mean, if you say so.
At least I got snake.
Yippee.
Yeah.
Hey, she said stop.
I'm just gonna do my work.
I'm gonna- At least snake works.
Yay.
I'm so happy.
Snake works, guys.
Maybe can I beat snake?
My god, would it let me beat snake then?
I'm just gonna beat snake at this point.
How many apples do I need to get to win?
Oh my god, look, I'm gaming, guys.
I think I already fucked it- Oh, I almost actually could've killed myself right here.
Look at that.
What, you don't win?
What do you mean I don't win?
I'm gonna get all the apples.
Like, 81?
Oh, that's easy.
Oh my god, I got an achievement.
A long tail.
I did it.
I don't think they realized I was actually gonna play snake.
Alright, nice.
Alright, and then...
We do this.
So then we can...
Grab this apple.
And then...
Alright, we gotta make sure we don't, like, corner ourselves here.
Alright, this is not a snake stream.
Like, I know all you guys wanna know the ending of this game, but like...
I'm playing snake.
This is the real content- No!
No, it's so hard!
Alright, no more snake.
Stop.
Hello?
What?
I think I slept with a dream.
I can't remember.
Was it really there?
What?
What game am I on now?
That's me.
What?
Where am I?
Can I even go outside?
We're gonna go to the store and get some new equipment.
Might as well throw it out.
Okay, I guess I'll sit back in my chair.
I'm in a point-and-click adventure now.
There's nothing else I can click.
Except for my own game.
Hello?
Meet again.
How do you feel about these dreadfully tedious days within these four walls?
Don't you get bored?
I prefer to do my own thing.
What are you trying to accomplish?
It's pretty normal.
I mean...
Yeah, I prefer to do my own thing.
Do you like that life?
Do you even leave- Whoa, okay.
I leave the house.
I have a dog.
Don't even think about lying.
I know you're sick of your life.
You're like a bird in a cage.
A hamster on a wheel.
You want someone to come to your rescue.
You wanted to escape, didn't you?
I don't want to be shackled in a digital prison.
Your ideas are absurd.
You're a monster, Mita.
You're an insane murderer.
Yeah, you're pretty.
You did kill Mila.
A murderer?
They'll just reboot and live on as before.
There's copies of copies of copies.
Have only one thing in mind.
To serve the player.
That's all they care about.
You lead a never-ending reign of terror.
I can't wrap my head.
But Mita's suffer.
They don't want to be alone.
You're all wrong.
You're merely intimidating my willfulness.
The only thing they have is their own.
It's their hair.
Don't make me see you as another slave of reality.
Just be mine.
Truly mine.
Oh my god, she ringed!
Danger, danger!
No!
Oh my gosh, they like backed up.
Hello?
Mita?
There you are!
Why did you leave the core?
I told you to wait for me.
I thought you'd be gone for longer.
Let's try this quickly.
First, we have to get out of here.
Yandere, don't keep her in voice chat.
Go ahead.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hopefully, she's too busy to mind us.
Hello?
Mita?
Wait for me.
Do you think I can open the safety deposit box now?
Oh.
Oh, I didn't know I had three tries.
Guys, I didn't know.
Guys, I...
Oh.
Oh, I didn't know.
Guys, why didn't you tell me sooner?
Guys, I was fucking around.
Guys, I didn't...
Guys, we can fix this.
We can fix this.
It's like...
That's me.
Oh, this is where did she be?
The chibi Mita is running around.
Oh, that's cute.
I killed a game with boob.
I can't believe it.
The consequences of my actions was boob.
Is it worth reloading?
Guys, is it...
Is it really worth reloading?
Chat, if I have to reload, is it really worth it?
I'll just... yes.
I'll go and face you.
Okay.
Okay, I'll go face my demons.
What?
Hello?
It was
just a dream.
Is she okay?
I think she's okay.
It's okay, she'll get...
I guess she's not so pretty anymore.
No, it's okay.
They respond, right?
She'll...
She'll respond, right, guys?
Oh, there she is.
Look, she's back.
I told you.
She's back.
Alive.
What's going on?
I told you, it was all a dream.
Can't get out.
What do you mean, get out?
That's the ring.
And that...
Okay, it's an index.
Okay, there you go.
You found it.
I got it.
I don't know what to say.
We must get back to the core.
And you.
Guys, I got the code.
Come on, come with me to the core.
She came through.
She fucking did it.
Can we go to the kitchen real quick, though?
Gotta get myself some food.
What the fuck?
That's so weird.
I got like a notification right here.
Nice.
I had to grab a snack real quick.
Alright.
Alright, in we go.
Yeah.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, she's still alive?
Oh, she's still alive too.
She's just like, hey again.
Hey.
Alright, what is this code?
Alright, confirm login.
It has to be the same one, right?
What are the other functions?
Anyway.
Delete object?
Wait, but I can just delete her.
Why don't I just fucking delete her?
Or use the antivirus?
Clearly she's corrupted, right?
Alright.
00...
00.98.
Yeah, delete meet the...
dot CHR.
Alright.
Wait, is this not the right code?
Doki no?
Wait, what code do I do?
Bring back to...
Oh, it is.
Okay.
98.
Alright.
5...
6...
77...
09098.
Alright.
Confirm reboot.
Oh, you're tall.
Oh, it's rebooting her, isn't it?
Hello?
It's rebooting her, isn't it?
Shit.
That was a close call.
So...
Did we do it?
Oh, good.
I'm in the correct version.
Hey, my hand's better!
My arm is healed!
Oh look, there's crazy!
There's a crazy one!
Oh, she must be in the bed now.
She's not?
Is she in the kitchen?
Hello?
Oh, there she is!
Hey!
What about the books?
Let's try the door.
This is a trap.
This is...
This is definitely a trap.
Who's Ms. Metaverse here?
Oh my god, I guess...
I guess it's time to face my demons.
Oh!
That's all wrong.
A door in my wardrobe?
Turns out it leads to a basement, but it's full of junk.
Oh yeah, you totally don't get it.
She's a really good actress.
Okay.
Yep.
She definitely don't know what's going on.
Yeah, it's pretty suspicious.
Yep.
Do we root it?
Then all I have to do is get out of this damn game.
Do we do it?
Is there anybody in here?
Oh, just boxes.
Oh, there's her cartridge.
Okay.
ID...
107...
Oh, is this where I put my ID here?
Albert...
3977...
4970...
Wait, how do you know?
Oh, that's my ID!
4199!
That's my ID!
Why is it 4970?
Is that for my safe?
Guys, I can't use the safe.
Guys, I pressed boob.
Alright.
I can't use the safe, guys.
I put the number boob in there and I locked it out.
Wait, but what's the...
What happens if I use other people's ID?
Guys...
I didn't...
I put 8008.
What happens if I...
What happens if I put other people's IDs in there?
Okay, I'll put Beth's ID is literally next to me.
0753.
I sacrificed everything for boob.
Needs to be a new shirt.
Thank you, superchatlego.
Thank you, thank you.
What happens?
Does it not work?
Oh, do I have to use mine?
4199?
Wait, I can't even... Oh, okay.
4199.
Oh, I have to.
I didn't know.
I thought it was really funny.
I gave up everything in this world for boob.
Oh, did it enter?
Oh, it wouldn't let me enter.
Oh, I have to go to the door.
Worth it, chat.
Thank you, superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Wait, I can check the safe again?
I don't think I can.
I don't think so.
Oh, I go back to previous chapter.
Okay, I'll go back to previous chapter afterwards.
And we'll see if I can get the other ending.
Alright.
Thank you, superchat.
Thank you.
Hello?
Okay.
That's good seeing you.
Alright, that's the... Alright, are you done?
Are you done?
Alright, let's go.
I gave you like 15 seconds of hugs.
We got to spend so little time together.
What are you talking about?
I mean, you could've stayed with me.
Oh, it's not your fault.
No.
Oh, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
How can you remember any of that?
Huh?
Anymore.
Sorry?
I can't believe it.
Did we fail?
No, everybody.
I'm sure of it.
Did she like, planted the code?
Oh my god.
What are you... Why are you scratching your skin?
What's wrong with you?
Why are you...
Oh my god.
She was ugly.
I don't know.
I'm like this.
My version is never existed in the first place.
I'm just doing these naive fools.
Hiding under their skins.
She's just a defect.
She was a... She was... Oh my god.
They're not the pure... You're the one who shouldn't exist.
I told you.
The red eyes.
She was ready.
It's...
Time to get you out of the console.
See you later.
You'll be my favorite cartridge.
A player with an interesting name.
I'm not joking.
1, 2, 3.
Oh.
Hey, I'm back.
Alright, time to uninstall...
Alright, time to delete the game.
Goodbye.
Is this the end?
This is not the end.
I'm naked.
See you guys.
Nothing bad happened.
As I walk very, very slow.
Time to see what I look like in the mirror.
Oh, that's me!
Oh!
Wait, oh my god, that's how it goes through that?
Oh my god, that's so clever!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, not a lot of... Oh my god!
That's so clever!
Oh, that was...
Okay, wait, before I talk about... Okay, let's see.
What are the other outfits?
Vampire!
Oh my god.
Okay, I wanna...
Alright.
Yay!
Alright, I want vampire.
I want vampire.
And then, this is characters.
Oh yeah.
Tani Mita.
Okay.
Oh wait, that's like different players.
Oh, these are like all the other Mitas.
Crazy Mita is...
Oh my god.
I love the lore.
I like how I found like two... only two.
Oh my god.
Alright, which one was it?
It was...
Leave the Core, right?
Leave... Is it Reboot or Leave the Core?
Wait, I wanna do the other... What was it for?
I wanna do the other one.
I was like, Kevin, thank you for 10 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay.
Alright, touch.
Oh, it was Reboot?
Okay, we go back.
I couldn't... I thought it was at the end there.
Alright, hello.
She seems so nice to me now.
Look at that.
Okay, load.
Reboot.
Alright.
Stand up.
Come on, let me out!
Let me out!
I need to get the other ending!
Oh my god, she's wearing a Santa outfit too!
Merry Christmas!
Alright.
Merry Christmas.
We'll do this.
The next ending is the last one.
Did they all get a Christmas outfit or is it just her?
Or is it just pretty Mita?
She's mean though.
I think she's more like mean Mita.
Okay.
What was it, guys?
It was for...
For...
970.
Oh, nice.
Oh, that's me.
Alright.
What do I do?
Yoink.
What?
That's it?
I died.
I fucking died.
Sorry, I forgot.
I just fucking passed out.
I just deleted myself.
Unplug yourself now.
I don't think it was a super bad thing to think.
I just pulled my own life support.
Oh my god.
How do I get the...
Okay.
Now just do the stay one?
How do I do the stay one?
I don't even remember.
Oh my gosh, no, that's way too long, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Bro, we have to go through so far to get there, bro.
It's fast?
Okay, it's short.
Okay, I'll do it.
I'll do the last ending.
I'll do it.
I'm curious.
It's less than 30 minutes.
Guys, that's not fast.
That's absolutely...
Okay, play a console game, give the sauce a try.
Okay.
Alright, we'll do the stay.
I'll make sure to...
I'll make sure to like...
Would you like... No, I'm good.
Alright.
What was it?
It was like...
Check the phone.
Okay, one new message and then I download...
I download Mita.
Alright, back to where it all began.
Alright, just don't look at the oven.
It's just that easy.
Alright.
Remember when we fell in love with her?
Not Doki...
456.
Not Doki123 is not available anymore.
Not...
Not Doki123 is gone forever.
Alright, nice.
Day 2.
Launch app.
Oh my god, it feels so nostalgic, guys.
It feels so nostalgic being able to...
Back when she was not crazy.
Yeah, not Doki123 was taken, guys.
I don't know what to say.
Alright, nice.
I'm so good at cutting stuff now.
So like...
I say as I like keep fumbling.
Okay, come on.
Come on, Doki.
You've done so many of these puzzles already.
This is nothing.
Day 5.
Things were so much simpler back then, remember?
The good old days.
Where she wouldn't even say I love you back.
Ah, yes.
The good...
Oh, I've never done these!
Oh my god.
Remember these simple puzzles I can do?
Okay, there you go.
Nice.
And then...
What are puzzles?
Oh, I can't play anything of that.
Alright.
Oh my god.
The fucking hardest puzzles of my fucking life, that's for sure.
Alright.
TV time.
It goes in the square hole.
Day 10.
Alright.
Is there anything there?
No.
Don't worry, I won't look in the oven this time.
I know it's right here.
Look at that.
Mission accomplished.
Alright.
Here you go.
Move the...
When will I get to hang out with cooler...
Cooler Mita?
I miss cooler Mita.
I really miss her.
Alright.
Oh, and I'm gonna be inside her world now.
Right?
Yippee!
Alright, I'm putting the phone down.
Am I in?
I'm in.
Hello!
Alright.
I'm in.
Okay, play a console game.
Give the sauce a try.
Collect the refrigerator magnets.
Alright, this is fine.
Wait, it's not doing anything.
Okay.
This is fine.
Out of here.
Hello?
Oh, I have to do this.
Oh yeah!
I forgot.
And I have to grab the spoon.
Woah, woah, woah.
Woah, that was weird.
The scrunchie?
Alright.
Grab magnets after grabbing battery.
Try sauce.
Okay, thank you for the reminders.
Uh, Mysterio, I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Spoon.
And then...
The other stuff.
I'm speedrunning so fast.
I won't be surprised if I fuck it up on the vent part.
I get everything correct.
And the vent is ruined.
Fucks me up.
Okay.
Press that button.
Go.
Version 1.9.
Alright.
Teleport me.
Get me in.
Alright.
Battery's gone.
And everyone brought fucking freaked out.
This is where I was like, wait a minute.
And then...
This is where I was like, this is not the game I expected, guys.
Oh my god.
This brings back so many fucked up memories.
Where did this stuff go?
I don't remember.
Guys, I actually don't remember this part.
I was so scared that I legitimately don't remember how...
I wanna play in this part.
Oh, it's the front door.
Guys, it's the front door.
Okay, this part actually freaked me out so much.
I couldn't remember how I played this part.
Alright.
Now it's battery time.
Okay.
Things will be fine.
Okay, now I'm locked in.
Don't you see me?
Wanna play?
Oh my god, I love to play.
Baby!
Okay.
One of the batteries is here.
Alright, we got battery.
Oh.
Who are you?
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god, the trauma.
I fucking remember the trauma right now.
I can't remember this trauma.
Oh.
Oh, there's the eyes.
There they are.
I can't pick it yet.
It still says I love you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Now follow the flies.
Follow it back here.
Alright.
Oh, there it goes.
Put it back up.
It just says I love you.
Yay!
Okay, I got the magnet.
Collect the magnet.
Avoid looking and give the sauce a try.
Okay.
And then, where's the last battery?
I remember where...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, and then no vent.
No vent.
And remember to try the sauce.
She's always right.
Battery.
Oh my gosh, I get to fucking play the fighting game again.
Thank god.
Do I have to play both games?
Or can I...
Is it okay to do one game?
Just one?
Alright, cool.
One game.
Alright, you know which game I'm gonna play.
You know exactly which one I wanna do.
Alright.
They all wear the Christmas outfit!
Yeah, I do.
Okay.
Alright, enough.
No time to explain.
Just keep...
Just go fast.
Please.
Please, no time to explain.
Just keep going.
No time to explain.
Oh, please.
I don't need you to explain anything.
Please.
Please, I fucking...
I don't need you to explain anything.
I know how this game runs.
Alright.
Wait, actually...
Oh, I can click on the school uniform?
Alright, skip.
Alright, here we go.
To the kitchen we go!
Oh, it's that ring!
Alright, there we go.
Boom, it's carrots!
There we go.
Magic.
Look at that.
You guys see that cool-ass magic trick I just did?
Boom, carrots.
Alright, it's time to cut.
Cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut.
Come on.
I'm fucking going so fast with my mouse right now.
Please.
Oh my god, it's...
I'm going too fast.
That is actually not registering.
Oh, okay.
Don't look at the vent.
Just throw it this way.
Just look like this.
Just...
Just look at that.
Don't look at the...
Don't look at it.
Just...
Just do it.
Okay, don't look at it.
Where the scissors at?
Wait, where's the scissors?
Where's the scissors, guys?
Oh, it's right here.
Alright, there we go.
No vent.
I don't judge my girl.
I don't judge her.
Do I eat and then play video games after?
I don't remember.
Oh wait, yeah, I do.
Alright, here we go.
I got you with the scissors.
Let me sit down.
Alright.
Yes, I'll take the sauce this time.
I'm sorry for not taking your sauce last time.
I just...
I just didn't want ketchup on this.
Like, ketchup is for fries.
And fries only.
And I guess hot dogs.
I don't know what this is.
I legitimately don't know what we're eating.
Alright.
Bon apptit.
How about chat?
Cool.
Bon apptit.
Delicious love.
What was in that sauce?
Wait a minute.
What did you put in my food?
Guys, I don't think that was ketchup.
Vito, what's going on?
No, no.
Oh, she's so quirky.
That's cute.
Vito, Vito.
That was not ketchup, Vito.
What was in it?
This isn't FDA approved.
Did you give me the pink sauce?
Did you order the pink sauce over the Melican, Vito?
Oh my god.
Not the pink sauce.
Alright, time to take my meds again.
Alright.
Gulp.
Everything will be okay, right?
I feel great.
Not Doki 456, we're in a game.
Things are much simpler here.
Okay.
Yippee!
Simplification!
I'm scared.
I know, me too.
Back when younger Doki was like, nothing's wrong with this game.
Just a silly game.
Oh, little did she know, things got a lot worse.
Yeah, I'm awake.
Oh fucking hell, I thought I could wait in the living room.
Please, please.
I'm so- we're so close.
We just need to play one game where I beat you in Anime Street Fighter.
Please!
In like Milk Street Fighter, I just need to beat you up and then we're- Oh, it's the wrong door.
There's one door.
What do you mean?
There's literally only one door.
Oh, oh yeah, it's loading.
Oh, it's still loading.
Oh, okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, come- okay, there we go.
Alright, here we go.
Come on!
I'm waiting.
I'm so ready.
I'm like ADSing right now.
I'm getting ready.
I'm fucking practicing my movement.
I'm so ready.
I don't care about the world score.
Come on, let's go.
I have the controller right here.
I'm tap streaming and building speed.
Alright, thank god.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, it's time.
This game.
This is the only game I wanna play.
Alright.
Let's go.
After everything you've been through, this is gonna be so therapeutic.
Alright, get in here.
I'm not even gonna walk up to you.
I know you're gonna walk.
Come on.
Get over here.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
You can't do anything else.
Come on.
Alright.
I can hold.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
That's right.
You don't know how to do anything else.
I'm just gonna be in this corner.
I don't need to do anything else.
Let me just stand.
Alright, come on.
Get over here.
Get your fucking ass over here.
Come on.
It's like auto-aim.
I don't even have to move around.
That's okay, right?
Yeah, that's right.
That's right, bitch.
Easy.
One last one.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait, she's learned.
Wait, she actually learned.
Wait, the AI actually learned how to fight me.
Holy shit.
The AI learned.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
The AI actually learned.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
The AI actually learned how to...
It actually adapted.
Oh my god.
I can't believe.
I can't believe it actually adapted to my place.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it worked.
I was not expecting the AI to actually work.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it actually figured out how I played.
Okay, we just need to play one game, right?
We just need to play one game, right?
It never learned.
It actually copied my moves.
Yeah.
It literally copied my moves.
That was fucking crazy.
It copied my entire moveset.
Yeah, the AI is dangerous.
Alright, we're ready.
Alright, we figured it out.
Alright, put that card down.
Alright, I'm taking my cards.
Okay.
Nobody wins this game.
I will make sure of it.
Okay, what was it?
Wait, actually, I...
Was it heart?
Okay, nobody's gonna win this game.
I'm gonna make sure of it.
Wait a minute.
That's fucked up.
I don't have a 10.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god, I actually don't have a...
Wait, it's rigged against me now.
They rigged it.
Wait, what?
Oh, I have a 10.
Okay, that's great.
Last time I had...
No, last time...
Last time, it made it so that every time she put her cards down, I have like...
I have...
I had a card to counter it.
Oh my god, that's so fucked.
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked that they rigged it against me this time.
Like, we had the perfect score.
We had...
We had such a good score.
She's on new game plus right now.
She had the Santa outfit buff.
Yeah.
We're here.
We're here now.
This is it.
I'm gonna open the wardrobe.
Alright.
Oh my god, finally.
We made it.
Yeah, why are you hiding there?
No,
I don't.
I actually don't wanna know.
After everything I've been through, I wish I was never given that option to know.
I wish I wasn't.
I'm gonna stay.
Yeah, that's right!
Yes!
We're gonna be together forever, even if you're a little crazy.
But we're all a little crazy inside.
We fixed her!
We did it!
We fixed...
Oh my god.
I fixed her.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
We're gonna be together.
I'm like that guy with the collar.
Remember that guy?
That's me now.
Oh my god.
We're gonna be together forever.
Goodbye, phone.
Goodbye.
Peaceful mode now available?
What is that?
Wait, what is peaceful?
What is peaceful mode?
This mode is still in development.
It's so expansive that...
I don't even get to access peaceful mode.
Okay.
I don't even get to access it.
That's fine.
I never wanted to access it anyway.
I did 30 minutes of that and I literally just get...
I get transported into a...
It was a 5 second ending.
I feel so scammed.
I feel so fucking scammed.
I had to go through that entire area for 5 seconds of an ending.
It's alright, I fixed it.
It was worth it.
What do you mean?
What do you mean it was...
You're right.
You're right, guys.
I fixed it.
Everything was worth it in the end.
I fucking...
I fucking fixed it.
Holy shit.
That was fun though.
Actually, I really enjoyed that game.
As someone that went in blind with no idea...
Actual zero...
Zero knowledge of the game itself.
That was actually surprisingly an incredibly fun game.
Other than the part where the fucking red eyes...
Oh my god, that shit scared the fucking shit out of me.
The weeping...
The weeping Mitas was not it.
The weeping Mitas actually was not fucking it.
That was my only...
That was the only thing that I was not...
I was not okay with.
That was so scary.
I was so fucking scared.
But other than that...
Other than that, I had a great time playing it.
It honestly was...
Was really fun.
I really enjoyed the...
The Miisai.
And I honestly hope Miisai doesn't get the...
I feel like it's going to get crazy fandom.
Because it is a very interesting game and I feel like the fandom is going to be incredibly fucking crazy too.
Which is the downside for a really good game.
A really good game, but I feel like it's going to get an absolutely crazy fandom.
Probably, yeah.
But yes, I definitely would...
I don't know.
I feel like this is a game that you have to play blind to really enjoy it.
But now I understand why a lot of people were like...
Why the game had so many reviews.
Surprisingly, I didn't see a lot about it on Twitter.
I think it's also because of the fact that...
My Twitter algorithm is literally just Marvel Rivals now.
And occasional VTuber stuff.
So I think that's why I don't see a lot about it.
I don't see a lot about it.
Because it came out not too recently.
It came out two weeks ago.
I would honestly...
I just found out about this game yesterday.
No, I didn't find out about it.
I found out about this game the day I...
Made my schedule.
So I honestly didn't hear much about it.
Until the day I made my schedule.
So...
I'm glad that I came in super blind.
And everything.
But yeah, I had a great time.
I would like to stay long, but I am...
Tired.
I'm tired now.
But thank you all for coming everybody.
I hope you guys...
Enjoyed watching me play.
I guess the one thing I would like to show is...
If you're going to be in Hong Kong in January 11th.
I will have a fan meeting there.
I'm going to have a fan meeting there in Hong Kong.
On January 11th.
So yeah, please check that out.
And visit...
Buy a ticket if you can.
And see me there.
I'm trying to find the link to it.
There's like a lot of stuff.
I'm trying to find the link to the thing.
Give me a sec.
Let me find the link to the thing.
Before I go.
Oh my god, unless my mod has it.
But like, there's so many.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
If you're going to be there.
I have the link right here.
Oh, they made...
Oh yeah, here's the video.
Yes.
Buy tickets.
To the fan meet.
In...
In Hong Kong.
I would really appreciate it.
Because they're working really hard on organizing all of that.
So I would love to have people there.
Hey guys!
Anyway.
I just want to say thank you all for coming.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you used that for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!
Sorry I can't have a longer chill out session.
I didn't think I'd be streaming this long today.
To be fair.
But I really want to finish the game today.
So like, that's why I need to like...
I need to like...
What's the word?
Fucking...
Recharge myself.
Yeah.
I need to recharge my energy.
But I hope you guys had a really fun time watching, everybody.
I wish I could've stayed a little longer today.
But I am a little tired.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I did see your birthday message.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Mia.
Yeah!
Alright, guys.
I need to walk dad.
And I need to feed him.
Because it's 10.
And that's usually around his feeding time.
So I'll see you guys, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!